Three,
two,
one,
the yes.
We live.
Not yet.
Pause,
hold.
Youtube.
Some sort of a struggle.
Yeah,
we're live.
Okay.
How are you?
You're a wheeler walker jr fantasy.
Um,
I,
maybe I will be.
You will,
you never heard of him before?
I hadn't.
I confess.
That's okay.
Um,
so first of all,
thank you.
Thanks for doing this.
Appreciate it.
Yeah,
no problem.
What is it like,
I mean,
I guess is the best way to get this
started.
What is it like being a person that grew
up in the Westboro Baptist Church?
For a person on the outside?
For me,
I,
when I think of that I think of like
this crazy,
hateful,
angry environment filled with like
really mean people that say horrible
things about gay people and all sorts of
other folks that I meet you and you're
super nice.
It seems so normal.
That is the conundrum.
So I mean a lot of the things,
the words that you just used to describe
the church,
that's definitely not how I experienced
it growing up for the most part.
Um,
I mean my family outside of when they're
out on the picket line,
their immune incredibly kind and gentle
and,
and compassionate.
And I think the biggest misconception
about the churches that they're
motivated by hatred and in their eyes,
it's the definition of loving what we
really thought we were doing,
what we were doing was loving our
neighbor.
So the first time that phrase appears in
the Bible,
it's in the context of when you see your
neighbor sending,
you have to rebuke him,
not just like watch him wander off on
this way to hell.
So that was how we saw it.
We thought we were warning people in and
giving them the only hopeful message
that could save them from eternity in
hell.
Was there ever any dissent amongst the,
the people that were in the church about
like how the message is being
distributed.
Like if you're holding up a sign that
says God hates fags,
and,
uh,
a gay guy who was being buried at a
funeral and you guys were there
protesting with those signs,
like who's ever anyone inside the
organization that was like,
Hey,
this is not the way to do it.
These people are suffering.
And morning,
not really.
I mean,
once,
once my grandfather,
uh,
it was,
if he was the one who kind of developed
that strategy,
he thought,
so,
you know,
this,
the example is for funerals,
if somebody,
if they're burying somebody,
uh,
so a soldier say,
or a gay person,
uh,
it's an example of the curses of God.
So God says,
if you obey me,
I'll bless you and if you disobeyed me,
all cursio.
So why soldiers?
So several times in the scriptures,
it's this connection between the sins of
the nation and,
uh,
the,
the punishments.
So for instance,
in the book of judges,
it says they chose new gods then was war
in their gates.
Uh,
and then,
um,
in the books of the Kings,
it says they,
um,
uh,
there fell down many slain because the
war was of God.
And then in the book of Hosea it says
they have deeply corrupted themselves.
Therefore I will remember their iniquity
and I will visit their sentence,
though they bring up their children,
yet will I buried them?
There shall not be a man left.
So it's these,
these threatenings,
these warnings from God that if you
disobeyed me,
I'm going to curse you.
So we would go to these soldiers,
these soldiers funerals to warn the
living,
to say that if,
if,
if you don't want to be likewise
punished,
you have to repent.
You have to change your ways and,
and obey God.
No
people that are also hardcore
Christians,
uh,
that also follow the word of God very
closely,
but still would see like what you guys
were doing at these funerals,
holding up these signs,
protesting were a soldier who supposedly
gave his life for our freedom,
right?
Supposedly they're over there fighting
so that we can be safe here and that you
guys are out there with these signs,
like there had to be a lot of people
that have likeminded views in
Christianity but still were furious.
Yeah,
absolutely.
And from our perspective,
we thought that they were substituting
their righteousness for the
righteousness of God.
So they were upset that we were out
there giving this message that that was
100 percent biblical and our from our
point of view,
and they,
God calls that compassion when he sends
his servants with his message.
So we thought even though they call
themselves Christians,
they're ignoring these vast swaths of
the Bible that,
that support what we were saying and how
we were saying it.
So I mean there was definitely a lot of,
a lot of pushback from people on all
sides but,
and especially from other Christians,
but we just thought they're not really
Christian because they're not following
this.
We understand.
So you guys were pretty much solidified
in your opinion.
It was a consensus.
It was like everybody thought you were
doing the right thing.
Right?
So I mean,
so that when the soldier's funerals,
when those protesting,
it was in June of 2005 that we started
protesting soldier's funerals.
How's it brought up?
So my grandfather had been in since
2005,
so the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan,
you know,
he'd been,
you see these things on the news,
uh,
and he,
he was the funeral funerals,
like what was going on at the funerals
and he said,
these aren't funerals,
these are patriotic pep rallies and
they're saying all these things about
God bless America.
Well God isn't blessing America,
God is cursing America,
so we have to go and,
and give a different message.
Um,
so that's how it came up initially.
but,
so I went to my first soldier's funeral
protest and then the following month in
July of 2005 and before I went.
So,
you know,
every time we would go to these things,
I was protesting from the time I was
five years old.
So when you go out on the,
you know,
to these protests,
a lot of times there would be a media
there.
They have people asking questions.
And I wasn't sure how I would answer if
somebody asked me,
why are you at this funeral?
I didn't,
I wasn't sure how I would answer it.
So like I felt very when I found that I
was going,
I thought I thought I need to,
um,
I need to understand this.
So I went to my mother and she brings
forth those verses that I just quoted to
you.
And several others.
We sat down as a family as we did every
night,
um,
you know,
to read the Bible and to talk about
world events and the church's
interpretation of these events in light
of their understanding of the scripture.
So,
you know,
she goes through and explains these,
very carefully.
And because her answers came from the
Bible,
I was,
that was my,
my foundation was that the Bible is the
infallible word of God.
And that it's true no matter what any
human thinks and that we have a duty to
obey at 100 percent,
no matter,
no matter what I think or feel otherwise
I have to bring my thoughts and opinions
in line with this.
So even though I had a lot of
trepidation at the beginning about going
to those funerals,
uh,
I very quickly acclimated to it,
you know,
as you do when you're in an environment
like that where everything depends on
you falling into line.
No.
What was it like when you first did it?
Like what was the reaction to other
people or you know,
other people's reaction to you
[inaudible].
So that very first one,
it was in Omaha,
Nebraska and it was incredibly tense.
Um,
so there was a bunch of cops.
We always,
every time we would go to protest
somewhere,
we would contact the police to make sure
that there would be a police presence
because people were tempted to end,
did,
you know,
would come after us physically and try
to assault us.
And again,
this has happened with some regularity.
So from the very earliest days of the
protesting,
we,
uh,
you know,
my mom and her generation,
you had made this decision to who I
should say many of them are lawyers.
So they would,
you know,
write letters from,
as,
as attorney saying,
we're going to be coming.
We're going to be protesting in your
city a peep.
This is what we do.
We hold signs on public sidewalks.
We are not violent.
We,
so explaining what a pro,
what are protests looked like and then,
and then saying if you want to avoid,
you know,
uh,
these kinds of violence that often
happens a be there.
So this first one,
how old were you in 2005?
I was 19.
So you were a kid,
you know,
but a grown kid and you know,
you're with your parents and this is the
first time you're protesting a veteran.
What,
what was that experience like?
So I'm standing across this floor,
standing across the street from the
church.
Like I said,
it's a,
was very solid,
very quiet.
There were,
which is not,
was not normal really for protests.
A lot of times we would be out there
singing and chanting and,
and making.
It was a big public display,
but this was a,
like I said,
incredibly tense.
Nobody was really talking,
nobody was really moving.
Um,
uh,
and you know,
the family was,
you know,
pulled up in a.
and I think it was in a limousine across
the street and the family got out and
looked around and saw us and they know
you guys were going to be there
beforehand because we always would
publicize that we would send out news
releases.
So they were aware that we were going to
be there.
Um,
and there were a bunch of,
I think they were marines,
uh,
like in dress blues,
standing there and they,
they looked incredibly angry and upset.
But like I said,
it was,
it was like,
it felt like at any moment if something
happened like that,
the whole situation could explode.
But again,
that's with the cops having the cops
standing there.
And so it was um,
it was,
it was pretty.
Uh,
it was,
it was really tense.
They weren't saying anything like,
no,
none of this.
Which like,
I was trying to say,
it's really unusual for protests like
that.
We,
a lot of times we would be exchanging,
you know,
we would,
we would of course would be yelling
about Bible verses and the hatred of God
and,
you know,
they would be talking about love and
tolerance and how we're wrong and not
Christian and,
but at this one it was,
it was very quiet.
It wasn't always like that.
So pretty quickly,
once again,
once we became acclimated to do those
protests,
um,
and also there,
have you heard of the Patriot guard
riders?
It was a group of motorcyclists who
decided to,
and they formed like an,
uh,
across the country.
So in every state there was a group of
these,
a motorcyclist who,
when they found out we were going to be
protesting somewhere,
they would go and,
you know,
rev their engines so that our words and
songs and such wouldn't be heard by the
family.
Uh,
and,
and they would hold American flags and
try to block,
you know,
it's always,
it's putting a buffer between us and the
family.
And uh,
so when,
when that started to happen,
it became almost like a game sometimes.
And in hindsight,
I,
this makes me cringe and,
and,
but,
but it became like this game of trying
to show that we were going to get our
message across no matter what any human
being wanted because we knew we were so
sure that this was what God wanted.
Wow.
What made you leave
a lot of things?
It started my very first sort of
conscious doubts came from conversations
on twitter.
So yeah,
something good drug.
Dm through twitter.
Yeah,
lots of good things.
I also met my husband there.
Oh,
there you go.
While I was still at the church,
it's kind of A.
I don't know that he would use that word
to describe himself.
I actually was just talking to Sam about
this and I was like,
when people,
the problem with the word.
Because when people,
when you say atheist,
people think jerk.
And like so many people do.
So many people think that like,
Oh,
you're absolutely certain that there is
no god.
And so it's,
it's a word that I hesitate to use to
describe myself too.
But,
but I'm not a believer.
I don't even know to say I'm not a
believer because I,
I love people,
I believe in people and that there is so
much hope and,
and for people and that we can,
I don't know.
Anyway,
so conversations you had on twitter did,
what do you like?
What,
what doors did the open your mind?
Right?
So I got on twitter and it was like an
extension of the picket line.
Right?
So go out there with picket signs and
you know,
people would come up to us and ask us
questions.
And so it was this,
it was a constant,
a constant conversation.
And so I got on twitter to take that,
you know,
to,
to the Internet,
to reach more people.
And so one of the first things I did
when I got on twitter was to attack this
Jewish man named David Abbott Ball,
who ran a blog called Julius.
He was listed as the second most
influential Jew on twitter on this
number one.
Um,
I actually can't remember.
Not Memorable and I'm part of my story.
I guess you can check it at the Jta is
list if you want to change it,
but anyway,
so he was listed as number two and uh,
so he responded initially with sarcasm
and,
and hostility.
Um,
but pretty quickly he sort of changed
tactics and started instead of like
mocking me,
although he still didn't do that some
too.
Um,
he was asking questions about our picket
signs and I started asking him questions
about Jewish theology because I wanted
to better know how to counter it,
you know,
to run the scriptures because I was sure
that they were wrong.
Jews killed Jesus and,
and they reject him as the Messiah.
And so all of these things,
um,
so,
right.
So we're having this back and forth and
this goes on for about a year and during
that year I've actually met him twice.
I protested him twice once to his
functions or was he giving speeches?
So in Long Beach actually at the Julius
Festival,
they had this Jewish cultural festival.
Great,
man.
That's great.
He's great.
So He.
Right.
So he was going to be there.
Uh,
and you know,
I went when I was protesting him,
uh,
and he came out to the picket line and
it was,
it was one of those like very rowdy
pickets.
There was a bunch of,
a counter protestors and they were,
it was,
I don't know,
guys,
dresses like the Easter bunny and Jesus
and you know,
it was actually got pretty violent.
So I was actually super violent.
Well,
yeah,
and the cops,
this I told you,
we called the cops,
the cops were just standing there
watching people like actively assaulting
us,
like hitting us.
And so we're like walking around trying
to,
you know,
to not be hit because we're not going to
hit back.
We weren't there,
like I said,
the churches very against violence,
like they're not going to be violent to
people or defend themselves just to.
So I was actually really glad when David
came out because he became like a buffer
between me and the rest of the counter
protestors because everybody could tell
that he was wearing his delicious shirt
and whatever.
Anyway,
so,
so the conversation continued there and
then also at another protest a six or
seven months later,
um,
and then,
uh,
it was not long after that second
protest,
we're talking again and he was asking
about one of Our signs that said death
penalty for fags and you know,
of,
I'm reiterating why the church believes
that it has in the book of Leviticus,
God calls for the death penalty for gay
gays.
And then enrollment swollen in the new
testament.
Uh,
it's reiterated so they commit such
things are worthy of death.
So,
um,
and so I'm telling David these things
and he says,
I'm like,
yeah,
but didn't Jesus say,
let he who is without sin cast the first
stone?
And I said,
what we always said to that,
which was a,
we're not casting stones were preaching
words.
And he said,
yeah,
but you're advocating that the
government cast stones.
And I remember,
you know,
this is all through twitter.
Sorry,
I see this message and I,
I kind of gasped.
And I was like,
I had never connected that Jesus there.
Of course,
he was talking about the death penalty
specifically about the death penalty and
we were advocating it and so I wasn't
sure how to respond,
but he David kept kept going.
He said,
and what about this member of your
church who had a child out of wedlock?
And I said,
what about it like that?
This is another point.
You know people,
it was common knowledge.
People knew about this and what though
this interface,
and we would say the standard of God
isn't sinlessness.
It's repentance,
so she doesn't deserve that punishment
because she repented.
She stopped,
she wasn't having premarital sex anymore
and she knows that it's wrong.
And she changed her mind and she changed
her conduct,
which is what repentance is.
And he said,
yeah,
but she would have been killed if you
had instituted the death penalty for
that sin.
And it was the first time again that I
connected that if you kill somebody,
as soon as they sin,
they you lose the opportunity to repent
and be forgiven.
And so again,
so I'm just sort of staring at my phone
and,
you know,
in Topeka,
Kansas,
he's in Jerusalem and I really quickly
ended the conversation,
I don't even remember quite how,
but it was just sort of this like I
hadn't,
I didn't know how to handle this because
like I said,
the church is full of lawyers.
They're very intelligent and their
arguments and their theology for the
most part is very well constructed and
super consistent.
And so for there to be this,
you know,
this,
this hypocrisy,
this contradiction I didn't like my
brain was I felt like it was exploding.
So I went to a couple of people in the
church,
including my mother.
Um,
and the response was,
feel free to stop me at any time,
by the way,
I feel like I'm filled.
That's,
um,
so she,
she reiterated the same verses that I
had told David that,
that supported our position,
but she didn't address the
contradiction.
And when I seem to unsatisfied with it,
uh,
she said I was getting wrapped around an
axle and a just sort of,
you know,
push it aside.
And the response was so just to shut,
shut me down and then to move onto the
next thing,
which is,
it's a very human thing,
right?
When somebody puts something in your
face that,
that is this contradiction that you're
not ready to deal with or that you
can't,
you,
you know what I mean?
You cannot,
you kind of sort of push it aside and
try not to.
So the way that I dealt with it was to a
stop holding the sign because I knew
that if somebody asked me about it,
I,
I couldn't defend it because I didn't,
I didn't believe it.
But there was nothing else I could do at
that point.
And,
but the importance of that conversation,
this is obviously just one small
contradiction and one small
inconsistency and a vast,
you know,
we still,
I still believed that everybody outside
the church was basically isn't
completely wrong and,
and evil and slash or delusional and
that the church was basically right,
except this one point.
Does anybody ever feel that it was bad?
Use slurs like to use some sort of
insulting term for gay people instead of
saying God hates gay people.
So at the very beginning they did use
the word gaze.
It was a big change it.
Well.
So my grandfather would say that gay is
a misnomer.
These people aren't happy,
they're committing suicide and they're,
and they're evil and abominable,
and they have no peace.
God has taken their,
their piece.
They're not happy.
So gay is a misnomer.
And so the word the word fag,
they say like Amos,
in the book of Amos,
there's a,
uh,
it's translated firebrand there.
So my grandfather would say the word fag
is an elegant metafarm.
And it's,
um,
gays,
you know,
a bunch of fags are a bundle of sticks,
right?
Uh,
used for kindling.
So gays are,
they,
they burned in their lust one toward
another and they fuel the fires of hell
in the fires of God's wrath.
So it's an elegant metaphor.
GRANDPA gramps would say,
um,
do you know the original metaphor was
really supposed to be?
You mean from the Bible?
No,
the word faggot.
Oh No,
actually means a bundle of woods,
a bundle of wood,
and they would use that expression to
describe a woman because a bundle of
wood is burdensome,
like carrying around a bundle of wood is
very burdensome.
So when they would call a woman a
Faggot,
there were saying that she was
burdensome so when they would call a man
of Faggot,
they would say that he is burdensome
like a woman,
like a bundle of wood,
like a non manly man.
They can't get work done along those
lines.
And then it became used by people
erroneous Lee saying that it was about
burning them and that they would burn
gay people because they would burn
faggots of wood.
But that's not really the case.
Just sounds cool.
Yeah,
I actually had never heard that.
yeah.
If you go see if he could find that
Jamie Google that,
uh,
the original term faggot meant burdened
bundle of wood and burdened some,
like a bundle of what caused me to think
about like carrying a bundle of wood,
especially if you didn't have a truck.
It's a huge pain in the ass.
That's kind of what the source of it
was.
Wow.
Yeah,
no,
I had no.
I had no
people use it wrong and the real problem
is the people that use it wrong or like
gay activists and they try to say how
horrible that word is because it was
used to represent how gay people were
burned,
but there's never been like a time in
history where like,
there's a whole series of gay people
that were like burnt,
you know,
it's just like they drowned witches and
things were done like real specifically,
but it's never been like a thing.
What do we got here?
The word faggot has been used in English
since the late 16th century is abusive
turn for women,
particularly old women are referenced to
homosexual sexuality may derive from
this,
uh,
there.
Why does it have to be so weird the way
you got it?
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
I can really get a Ba,
ba blah.
So there it is an alternative
possibilities that the word connected
with the practice of fagging in British
private schools in which younger boys
performed potentially sexual duties for
older boys.
Although the word faggot was never used
in this context
thrown,
thrown around,
but the big one means the bundle of
wood,
the bundle of sticks.
What's that,
Jamie?
What are you got something awkward to be
carried is right.
Yes,
exactly burdensome.
So that's where it comes from.
A really didn't have anything to do with
burning people,
but like they will,
they'll repeat it like to make a big
point,
like a big dramatic point,
but it's know melodramatic.
You would think I would know this given
our respective histories,
but I literally had never heard this in
my life.
Accordant distinction for why people use
that term because it's really just that
they're annoying.
I mean it's really just,
you know,
they just think of some non manly man
who can't get things done and he's
probably crying all the time.
These burdensome from
my experience of gay people since we
left,
obviously much more,
uh,
maybe reflective of reality.
A has not been.
What has it been like an impossibly
wonderful.
Don't overcompensate because you're
getting out of this bad environment.
I'll take you down to Santa Monica
Boulevard,
the of the guest spots on earth.
You'll see dudes would cut off shorts
and you'll change your tune.
What are they doing?
Well,
I mean,
I'm not trying to like to paint
everybody with the one brush now either
been amazing.
As soon as you start being attracted to
men,
something happens.
They become different than every other
people.
Right?
Other world.
So,
I mean,
right after we left,
like at first I thought we have to hide
from the past forever and my sister and
I should say left together.
Um,
how old were you guys?
So I was 26.
I was almost 27.
Did you have a long conversation before
he did it?
Many memories.
About four months before between when I
first talked to her about leaving.
What was the first initial conversation
and how did you gather up the courage to
even sort of breach the subject?
Uh,
it was really terrifying and awful
because,
I mean,
I remember from the time I was very
young,
um,
there's this passage in deuteronomy that
my mom would quote and it's about,
you know,
if somebody,
uh,
if,
if your friend
did somebody close to you,
your,
your relatives,
somebody comes up to you and says,
let us go and serve other gods.
Like somebody secretly says to you those
things,
you have to stone them and you the one
that they came to,
you're supposed to be the first one to.
And my family's not stoning people.
Um,
but they do though,
if it's centered in the Bible.
And someone said,
hey,
we got a,
we have to serve this golden cow.
So they,
we also have an in the new testament,
it talks about rendering unto Caesar the
things that are Caesar's and to God's
the things that are got.
So we also have to obey the law of man.
We have to obey the law of sin and
weren't.
So we're not supposed to be.
I'm just so loved man supersedes the law
of God.
We're supposed to be obedient to the
laws of men.
But also,
I mean there this kind of a complicated,
I'm a little bit of theology where it
sort of undid a lot of the mosaic code
that we didn't actually have to follow
those things.
But honestly,
I don't know,
I think it's the whole,
I think it's like the death penalty for
a fag thing.
So like if they still believe that that
punishment is applicable,
then then we should be trying to
convince the government lobbying the
government to like with those signs.
So I'm so that I,
it was my sister.
If I went to her and said these things
to her,
she could easily have turned around and
told my parents not as a,
it's a culture of tattle tales,
not out of bad intention,
but because they believe that they're
trying to help you.
They don't want you to go down a bad
path.
So.
So we know when I,
it was,
it was.
I first thought of leaving on June was
July fourth and I was with my sister at
the time and when it first occurred to
me that I might,
that I might have to leave the church or
that the church might be wrong.
I thought I had to leave like that
second because if it even occurred to me
that meant I didn't belong there and
that God was going to punish me and that
I just felt like immediately so much
guilt and like I was a betrayer.
Was all your social life connected still
to the church?
Yeah.
And was this where had you already known
your husband by then?
I had,
yeah,
he was definitely part of it.
So,
but like it wasn't like that.
It's like the beginning,
like,
so,
so he was just another person on twitter
at first.
Um,
and it was,
it was,
it was like friendly conversation and
this went over to the,
you know,
for the course of several months.
Um,
I dunno,
eight,
eight or eight months or so,
seven or eight months.
And then it was never,
there was never anything about feelings
or you know,
relationships are,
all that stuff is totally for ventures.
No,
nothing like that.
Like not even like,
not even anything,
like nothing.
Like it's just that my mind didn't work
that way and there is,
there can be no relationship like that
with outsiders but outsiders,
outsiders,
so you know,
and I,
I actually thought I was never going to
get married because most of the people
in the church,
about 80 percent or so of the people,
the church,
there's only 80 people or so anyway
where my immediate and extended family.
So I thought there's no way that I'm
going to,
I'm just not going to get married.
That it was,
it wasn't,
it wasn't like an like an easy thing at
first,
but it was just,
it was just the facts on the ground,
you know,
like I could actually ground where you
had to date someone inside the church.
There was only 80 people in the church.
They're all your family.
You can't date your family.
Fuck yeah.
I mean,
I should say there were a couple of
people my age and they came,
they had just joined the church,
like,
you know,
that.
But I had no,
like,
I had no interest in any of them and it
was pickens
and uh,
but yeah,
it's,
it was kind of strange,
but I,
so I actually had a dream about meeting
I should say.
Also my husband at the time,
I didn't know,
he was totally anonymous on twitter,
like it's just his words.
I didn't know what he looked like.
I didn't know,
you know,
his name or where he lived or anything
about him except except these words.
Um,
and he was,
he was just curious and kind and,
and that sort of.
And He loved people and so he would sort
of always be pushing,
pushing the conversation back to.
It's like I'm giving,
it looks like I've told you all those
verses about protesting funerals and why
we have to go and do this and the
importance of it and why we have to
thank God for these tragedies because
God is sovereign and he's in control.
So I'm,
I'm talking about the scripturally,
like the justifying all these things and
he kept pushing it back to because he's
not super well versed in the Bible so he
didn't know how to like I see that the
Bible says these things,
but what about the family?
Like I just cannot imagine going and
doing these things to people and so this
is all happening like on as I'm.
So I'm also still having conversations
on twitter with so many other people.
So it's like twitter became this like
empathy machine for me.
Like so it's not just like on a picket
line where people are butting heads and
arguing and debating and,
and yelling and it,
it's,
I'm,
yes,
having these can be kind of aggressive
conversations.
But I'm also seeing like photos of their
cats and them,
you know,
exchanging,
joking with our friends.
And so I'm seeing a side of people and
sort of being immersed in this community
in a way that I had never been before.
And so it was really,
it's like I'm trying to say like when
you say why don't you leave?
Like it took,
it was so much sort of happening around
this time.
So when,
by the time this pile up of things,
um,
you know,
and I'm processing it as I'm going
through this,
I'm also talking to my sister and,
and she was the only and other people in
the church,
but she was the only person,
if I ever had a doubt or a question or
a,
like,
if I thought we're doing something wrong
here,
she was the only person who would say,
yeah,
you're right.
That doesn't make sense that I should
say my sister is,
um,
creative and artistic and had a,
like a little bit of a reputation for
being kind of rebellious.
Not as like submissive as my me and our
other sister.
Um,
so it was just this dynamic of,
uh,
you know,
between the two of us were,
she was the only person I could fully
articulate my thoughts and feelings to.
Um,
and so when I first thought of leaving
and I turned around and I thought I
literally,
it was,
we were painting at a friend's house,
painting the walls and I,
I turned around to set my paintbrush
down.
I thought it had to go and leave that
second and I turned around and saw my
sister and I thought I can't leave
without talking to her.
So the next day I,
um,
she came home from work over the lunch
hour and we would always like go up to
my room and we were talking about all
these doubts we were having and I was
crying and I put my head in her lap and,
and I couldn't even art,
like articulating the idea of leaving
was too much like it,
it's,
it's terrifying.
Um,
and it just seemed like impossible.
And I said,
um,
what if we weren't here?
And she said,
what do you mean?
And I said,
what if we were somewhere else?
And so that starts this conversation
where,
you know,
I cannot let go of all the things that I
thought that the church was doing wrong,
that are where our theology was wrong,
where we were applying it wrong,
I mean,
in a way that,
that was destructive and unscriptural,
um,
and she kept pushing the conversation
back to we're never going to see our
family again.
We're going to lose everyone and
everything that's ever been important to
us.
There is no hope outside this church.
All the things that we had learned about
outsiders that you know,
that they were evil and they could never
truly love each other or care about care
about one another.
They're really just enabling one another
on the path to hell.
So,
and so this,
this back and forth,
you know,
it goes on for about four months before
we finally actually left and,
uh,
it was as bad or worse and I could have
imagined.
But to get back to the,
well,
let's get to that bad or worse,
you could have ever imagined.
So I should show you left.
How did you leave?
Uh,
we,
we're talking to my parents and,
you know,
and it was another,
another issue had come up and I,
I couldn't,
we couldn't,
it was a battle that we weren't going to
fight again.
W W we can,
I should say in those four months,
I kept trying to articulate these doubts
in a way that the church would accept,
like trying to convince them not being
as open.
But as time went on I became more and
more open about,
about these questions and doubts and I
just,
I,
I couldn't,
we couldn't fight it anymore.
I just looked at grace and I said we
have to go.
And because we,
and I should say also we had already
been packing like we had.
We had started packing her things about
a little over a month before that and we
had started like taking boxes to our
friend's house.
Um,
and with the understanding,
he's actually our,
he was our high school English teacher,
um,
that we had kept up with on twitter.
And He,
you know,
we basically,
I told him,
you know,
if something changes,
if the church changes and these things
get better,
then we'll,
we'll,
we'll take a lot of stuff back and just
pretend like none of this ever happened
and he was just,
you know,
understanding and compassionate and
really supportive.
Um,
but,
so we had done all this stuff already,
but we actually had to go and pack the
rest of our things.
So we walk out of our parents' bedroom
and went and started packing and,
you know,
people started coming,
my brother and some of the elders and my
aunt,
my cousin,
you know,
people I,
we were very close,
like our whole,
my whole life revolved around the
church.
And so to look these people in the face
and say that,
you know,
this,
the,
you know,
the US,
them mentality,
it,
the bonds that are created in
environments like that are incredibly
strong.
At least they were in our church.
And again,
most of these people are also my family.
Um,
so it was,
it was awful.
Um,
and I'm crying and packing and trying to
explain to them why,
why leaving and I can hardly talk,
you know,
just,
I was so overwhelmed,
but I'm literally had to go back the
next day with a u haul to get the rest
of our stuff more.
Our parents helped us pack.
It's not,
it's not one of those,
uh,
like there are some groups like that
where they don't want you to leave.
They'll,
they'll try to stop you from leaving.
Like I heard,
um,
scientology that miscavige I.
Canberra's Ron.
Yeah.
He was talking about like fists,
like actual,
um,
obstacles to you leaving like
physically,
like they're not gonna you can't get out
of the gate,
like nothing like that,
you know,
my,
they always would say this is a
volunteer army and if you don't want to
be here then you don't belong here.
So it's just the,
uh,
it's the threat of losing everything and
everyone
being ostracized by and just sort of
expelled into this world that you
believe and have always believed is as
evil and without hope and doomed.
So how did you do it?
How did you get all your stuff packed?
People coming in there saying,
yeah,
I mean like they're,
they're,
they're trying to convince us,
but once they understand that we're not
being convinced that,
that,
you know,
they,
they walked away.
So I mean that night our dad dropped us
off at a hotel and then Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Like it's,
it's,
it's so immediate that you become this,
you become other.
You become an outsider at like in the
next morning when he went back,
I rang the doorbell.
I rang the doorbell and I lived in that
house from the day I was born.
Whoa.
Felt like you had to ring the doorbell
is not my world.
Yeah.
Wow.
Chris was like,
why don't you think
the doorbell?
And it was like,
there's no other.
There is nothing else like it.
This is not our home,
this is not.
So we go and we're packing all of our
things.
It was just,
it was awful just to.
I had been in those four months I had
been so terrified of.
Because I know knowing what was coming,
like just imagine you're going to lose
everyone in your life that you're just
going to like,
you're not going to like how your
parents met and fell in love or like
your grandparents and family recipes and
photos and memories and what did the
House list?
I'm like taking photos and voice
recordings and just all the time,
like in every.
It was just,
it's just,
it's overwhelming.
It's just um,
but did,
was there also like a feeling of relief?
Was there also a feeling of like we
actually did it.
I'm actually doing it.
It's actually happening.
I'm going to get away from this.
I know this isn't real.
I know this isn't right.
Did you understand that?
It was a cult.
So I was really against and I still
don't attend not to use that word.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a fine shorthand.
I guess for some it there are aspects of
the church that are not cultish for
sure.
Like,
like,
like what I just kept saying like
there's no,
they're not trying to get your money.
They're not trying to,
like the,
not some charismatic leader trying to
have sex with everybody's wives and
children or whatever.
It's nothing like that,
but there are definitely aspects that
are cultish.
The fact that you can't,
there is no such thing as agreeing to
disagree.
Like that's.
And the,
the penalty for disagreeing,
uh,
is so high.
Like,
so there are things like that that,
that are definitely quote like,
but um,
but I was definitely,
I was not in that in that moment.
I was not okay with using that term for
sure.
Right.
It was definitely,
uh,
it was,
it took a lot of time
and well it's a derogatory term,
but what it represents is an ideology
that a group subscribes to.
It doesn't necessarily have to have all
the negative ramifications of an
ideology for the fit into the category
of a call.
Right.
Yeah.
And I,
and I totally understand that now,
which is why like,
you know,
if somebody says it,
I sometimes will,
will say there are things that aren't
cold,
like,
and explain what I think is not.
But I'm also,
I don't do it every single time.
Like I understand that it's the,
so you get all your stuff after you ring
the doorbell,
you're gone.
And then how do you like enter into the
world?
Did you have a job back then or did you
have a job with the church?
Is the job of the church working for the
law firm?
So it's home job,
family
life,
just,
just everything all at once.
Um,
and then also of course you're going
into a world that I had just spent my
entire life,
you know,
protesting and just,
it's so crazy when I look back now at,
at videos,
which I couldn't do for a long time,
but there's tons of videos and
interviews and documentaries that,
you know,
or I'm,
I'm answering all these questions and I,
I,
it's,
it's crazy.
Were you there when Luther came to do
the documentary?
Did you talk to him while he was there?
Both Times.
He
was the first time it was a,
he was really super nice.
Um,
you know,
he came and can,
we were like making egg rolls together
and like going bowling and jumping on
the trampoline and,
and yeah,
he would come to pickathon and it was
really funny because like the,
so he came for three weeks but three
weeks,
like a month,
like one month he came for a week in the
next month,
came for another week and then came
again.
So the first time,
like I didn't know anything about him or
who he was really.
I mean I knew it was one of the BBC
obviously in that,
um,
but I hadn't seen any of his stuff.
And then before he came the next time,
uh,
I was supposed to be studying for a test
or something.
I was in college and uh,
I was procrastinating.
So I look on Youtube and find this
documentary that he did do,
do you know the one though?
I'm white supremacy than Nazis.
Louis and the Nazis.
So I watched that entire documentary and
I was like,
ugh.
Like I know what his angle is,
like the,
Oh,
these poor kids,
they were raised in this and they don't
know any better.
And at the time I was kind of indignant
because I was like,
I am a thinking person,
you know,
like I at all my life growing up,
like it wasn't ever just like I
explained about the soldier's funerals,
like I never just just went along with
something like I wanted to understand
why I needed to understand that it was
scriptural and from the Bible and so if
you could show me that then,
but like I am a curious person.
So,
but I just had never obviously
questioned like the,
the most foundational premises of our
belief system,
which is the Bible is the infallible
word of God and Westboro Baptist Church
are the only ones who have,
who can understand it correctly.
I just,
I just never,
I never really got got past that because
if it was in the Bible and it made sense
to me then it was fine.
So anyway,
so I was kind of indignant when I saw
what Lloyd was trying to do.
Like,
we're just poor children and,
and um,
so,
and I hadn't told my family and so then
everybody,
you know,
everybody knew about it,
um,
this,
you know,
what he was doing and I remember telling
him something about how he was,
it was insidious,
what he was doing because he was not
being honest.
He was being really friendly but not
being honest about what he really
thought about us.
Uh,
anyway,
well,
he said actually he actually addressed
it specifically in the second
documentary.
He said,
you've been saying this but,
but I've never pretended to agree with
you.
I've never,
I've been pretty,
pretty honest about it and I'm an
atheist.
I don't believe that what you're doing
is right.
I don't believe the Bible is the word of
God than at a.
um,
and so I,
of course then he's right.
He was exactly right.
Um,
but
I definitely couldn't see it at the
time.
Um,
will you leave,
you get out and then what do you do?
Do you get a job?
So I thought immediately.
So I,
my degree is in finance,
so I went through business school,
all these people saying,
you know,
start saving for retirement immediately
that it so,
and you know,
we believe that the doom of the world
was eminent.
So I never really did that.
So end of days type stuff.
Yeah.
So you were thinking that because of all
the sin,
one day there's going to be a reckoning
and all the Christians are going to
vanish.
Yep.
Destruction is eminent.
Was one of our sites.
Did you guys ever watched that movie?
Was terrible too terrible movies with
Kirk Cameron,
uh,
about the apocalypse.
God Damn left behind.
No,
they're so good.
You should watch them said they were
terrible.
I will.
Watch are terrible,
but they're so good.
They're so bad that they become like,
oh my God,
what the fuck is this?
Did you ever meet Kirk Cameron?
No,
I want to meet that dude.
Mm,
no,
I,
it's really funny.
Uh,
you listened to Sam's Sam Harris'
podcast?
Yes.
So this episode with Lawrence,
right?
He said something like Lawrence Wright
said,
said something like that.
Got Through of going clear the book on
Scientology.
Yes,
yes.
He said,
um,
he talks about Freud,
the narcissism of small differences and
I was like,
oh my God,
yes.
Like we other Christians,
like where some of our biggest targets
and we,
it would be like the smallest things.
Like for instance,
there was like one church that we had
some kind of like very little
affiliation with in the early days of
the picketing.
And uh,
then there are women started to cut
their hair.
Women are not allowed to cut their hair.
Cut your hair at all.
We weren't allowed to cut her hair at
all.
Yeah.
No.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Because of a Bible.
Verse versa.
Oh,
that's first corinthians 11,
14.
I think.
Actually it says I'm a woman's hair is
her glory.
He says,
don't you know,
it doesn't nature itself teach you that.
It's a shame for a man to have long
hair,
but a woman's hair is her glory and it's
given to her for a covering.
So it.
And it says a long hair.
Right?
So my grandmother interpreted that to
mean uncut,
which again,
like I,
I,
I did not,
we didn't believe in interpretation at
the church,
like the fact that he was adding
something into the Bible that wasn't
there before because obviously you can
have long hair without install,
cut in.
But uh,
but it's like if long hair is good than
uncut,
better so.
And he had his rules.
Oh,
what about clothes?
Like how do you reconcile the fact that
you're not supposed to wear two
different types of cloth
so that.
So the,
the,
the church sees this as a distinction
between the ceremonial law of Moses and
the moral law,
ceremonial laws,
like mixed fabrics and keeping kosher
penalty by death of mixed fabrics.
I actually can't remember,
but we just simply preposterous like
that.
We didn't worry about it.
Oh.
Because we thought these passages in the
new testament said you don't have to
follow those ceremonial laws.
So we didn't worry about it.
But did you guys spend any time
researching the actual history of the
New Testament?
Like how it was constructed?
So not.
I mean some.
Yes,
but not really because in our minds a
god is sovereign,
right?
So the church believes predestination,
so God controls
everything and everyone.
So God controlled the construction of
the new testament as well.
Exactly right.
Even though it was done by men,
it was God's will to have it the.
So it was all God's word.
Yep,
exactly.
How convenient.
You just don't have to.
You don't have to ask those questions,
but what about the fact that it was like
Constantine wasn't even a Christian
until his death bed?
Is that because God didn't want it to be
that way?
It's just,
it doesn't.
It's irrelevant.
It's a nice sweet loophole.
If you could just say that it's God's
will.
God knew the entire time.
Don't worry about it,
but it's a bunch of men wrote it.
Yeah.
What they did,
because God let them do it.
But then the question is which version?
Which is another question I sort of
instinctively avoided.
It's like atheists would ask this
question like why the King James version
and uh,
you know,
you can't really answer it because it
grant said so,
like,
that's not to say that my grandfather
was the pastor pastor,
the pastor for the founded the Westboro
Baptist church.
I don't think we did,
but I think everybody kind of knows.
So when I say grandpa was Grandpa Fred
Phelps.
Yes,
exactly.
Um,
anyway,
just wanted to close that loop.
So just like,
what was the,
what was the thought process behind
like,
just accepting that kind of stuff?
Like did your grandfather ever bring up
the even older versions of the Bible
that they were finding like what was his
thoughts on like the Dead Sea Scrolls
and things along those lines just didn't
address.
It just didn't matter.
Because again,
it's all God's word anyway.
It's God's will.
It's God's word.
It's so.
It's so fascinating when someone's so
rigid with their belief system,
it's like,
this is it,
and this is.
And as long as you believe that it's all
God's will is like,
oh,
well it's God's will.
Seriously,
put the New Testament was written by
Constantine,
a bunch of bishops and others,
God's will and God,
let them do it and not just let them do
it,
but caused him,
caused them,
forced it,
made it happen.
He knows what he's doing,
absolutely every,
every word of our conversation.
God allow all the sodomy and all the
crazy shit going on.
Why does God allow that?
So this is why I'm not a Christian
anymore.
You're confused and you're like,
what the?
Well,
so there's this passage in Romans nine.
it's not.
It's not the only reason I should say,
but,
but I have,
I have real trouble with this.
And I think it's,
it's still hard for me to say I think
this is evil,
but I think this is evil.
There's this passage in enrollments nine
that talks about it gives us an analogy
of God as potter and humans as clay in
his hands,
and he uses the example of Jacob and
Esau who in the Bible,
Jacob and Esau were twins and says,
well,
they were yet in the womb before either
of them had done good or evil.
God loved Jacob and hated Esau and it so
it paints this picture of God.
It says,
what if God willing to show his wrath
and make his power known,
endured with much long suffering,
the vessels of wrath made for
destruction,
so it says,
God created some people as vessels of
mercy,
people that he loves and others as
vessels of wrath made for destruction,
so made for the express purpose of
destroying them,
torturing them in hell for eternity.
So and then so he paul,
who's writing he,
he paints this picture,
God making you do all of the things that
you do and then blessing some and
cursing others.
And he says,
well,
you'll,
you're gonna.
Ask Me then why does God yet find fault
for who is resisted as well?
Right?
So you guys making you do it,
why is he punishing you for it?
Right?
If God's Megan do a horrible thing and
you resist as well,
you can't resist as well.
So he makes you do it and then he
punishes you for it.
And the answer is you don't get to ask
that question.
It says nay,
but o man who are either applies against
God shall the thing formed,
say to him that formed it.
Why Hast Thou made me this?
Can you just don't get to ask that
question?
And to me,
I say this is I've asked for.
I spent a long time talking to
Christians,
uh,
and you know,
people have mostly Christians because
it's obviously it's new testament,
so,
and,
but also talking to Jewish people about
the old testament and found so many of
the like interpretations.
So many of our beliefs are not,
they're not fully supported by,
by the Bible and that there are so many
different ways of interpreting so many
of our,
the more destructive of our beliefs,
but that one,
I have not found any explanation for
that passage.
That's anything that makes any sense,
that's consistent with the text and,
and not evil.
And I just,
I didn't,
I thought I couldn't ask that question
for so long when I was at the church.
Right?
I thought,
I just have to accept this.
This is the truth and nothing that I
feel or think matters against it.
Um,
but now I,
I can't not think.
Of course you cannot ask the questions.
Yeah.
That's got to be so strict.
It's also strange when you read the
passages in the Bible,
in their vowel and thigh and you go,
wow,
like what a weird.
Like you're reading something in a style
of communicating and thinking that we
don't even use anymore.
Like how strange is that?
Like how like if you had a conversation
with a rational person and they started
talking and thou and thy,
you'd be like,
what are you,
why are you using those words?
Like what's going on here?
Are you okay?
Like are you a crazy person?
But as long as you're quoting some
ancient stuff,
you're allowed to do it.
Like,
and it just,
it sort of highlights how bizarre
scripture really is and how bizarre
these ideological imperatives,
these ideological,
like pathways that are just completely
rigid and carbon.
So you have to follow them,
but then you're listening.
You didn't,
nobody even talks like this anymore.
Like this is such a strange.
And they didn't even talk like that.
Then when they wrote it,
because you're with something that was
in ancient Hebrew and then it was
translated to Latin is translated into
Greek and by the time it gets to English
like,
boy,
what a terrible game of telephone,
you know that the grape vine.
Great.
So it's just,
these are the questions that I never
thought I could ask her that again,
that it didn't matter because if God or
you know,
for ordained all of it and then it
wasn't irrelevant.
But there's also A.
I mean like there is so in this,
I was talking to Sam Harris about this
this morning.
He like,
there's so many things in the Bible that
I find so much good there also.
And unlike the language is something
that like,
yeah,
I know it sounds so weird to people but
to a lot of people,
but uh,
like the King James,
like I,
I grew up like,
again,
I,
my mother was reading this to us every,
every night.
And so these words,
there's actually a passage.
It says,
I found that like talking to God,
I found by words and I did eat them and
they were unto me the joy and rejoicing
of my heart.
Right?
So it was this thing where I loved it.
I loved,
I loved these ideas.
I thought I thought it was the truth.
And I thought it was like the definition
of goodness because God did it and God
said it.
And,
but even now,
like there's this one passage that I,
I really love.
It says,
um,
by long forbearing as a prince persuaded
and a soft tongue break at the bone that
lasts.
Like that's,
that's,
it's a soft tongue break at the bone
that,
that phrase.
I love the imagery.
I love the like,
cause you know,
I did this Ted talk a few months ago
and,
and uh,
you know,
it was,
it was kind of about this like modern
political discourse,
this,
this tribalism,
this is becoming this,
you know,
these calcified positions and,
and failures of empathy and,
and,
uh,
like people think that because,
you know,
they're so sure that they're right,
that their position is the right
position.
They're willing to talk to the other
side in ways that they're just,
it's just,
it's terrible.
It's the way that I did at the church.
It's the way that it's,
you know,
that dismissive,
condescending,
you know,
just a hostile,
aggressive.
And that's like it.
That's not it.
When people don't respond to it,
like they respond.
It's whole complimentary behavior,
right?
So when somebody approaches you a
certain way,
you tend to respond in kind.
So if somebody comes to you in kindness
and compassion,
you tend to respond,
you know,
in,
in that way also.
And when you are angry and aggressive
and hostile,
like it just elicits the same reaction.
People get defensive and uh,
but that,
that verse,
I love that verse.
It's a beautiful verse.
Well,
there's obviously some wisdom from what
those people were writing down and
trying to translate what that wisdom
was.
There was some really fascinating
pastures to me.
It's always been most fascinating as a
time capsule,
like when read it,
uh,
Mike.
Well,
regardless of who translated this
regard,
this is still a thousand year old book
at the very least in terms of,
you know,
or 2000 years old.
Like that alone is really amazing when
you're reading the thoughts and the
ideas of how someone was perceiving the
world 2000 years ago or roughly,
you know,
there's something to it where you are.
It also solidifies in my mind how
briefly human beings have been conscious
of their time here on earth 2000 years
ago is not very long.
I mean,
it seems like an incredibly long time
for a personal one of those to be 100.
But in terms of the age of the,
the human race itself,
which I think they just backdated again,
they found a new discovery where they
pushed back the oldest known human being
by over a thousand dollars 100,000 years
yesterday,
some new discovery,
some new bones.
Wow.
So now they know modern human beings
have been around for at least 300,000
years.
It's probably going to go back even
further than that.
They don't even know.
But,
um,
but that's so cool.
Like I was gonna say,
I actually think I'm Rob Wolf.
Oldest Homo sapiens species discovered
in Morocco.
Yeah.
What does it say?
Time.
Okay.
Yeah.
At 100,000 years to the history of
modern human fossils,
these bones are from early anatomically
modern humans,
our own species,
homo sapiens with a mixture of modern
and primitive traits and international
team of anthropologists.
Paleontologists and evolutionary
scientists report a pair of papers
published on Wednesday and the Journal
Medicine Journal Nature.
Um,
evolutionary.
What was the,
what was evolution talk like back at
home?
Um,
we didn't believe it to how old?
What about dinosaurs,
right?
Young Earth creationism.
One of the elders said something like,
God brought baby dinos on the arc.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't make it.
Yeah,
they drown.
I don't know,
we just,
it was not a,
anytime there was any conflict or
apparent conflicts between the Bible
and,
uh,
evidence,
physical evidence,
we just believe the Bible like,
because it's worse.
Yeah.
So Bible.
Wow.
But what you're saying about like
ancient wisdom,
like there was this,
uh,
so my husband,
um,
he got super into Paleo a few years ago
and uh,
he read John [inaudible] book,
uh,
the Paleo manifesto and he made me read
one chapter of it and it was called
Moses the microbiologist and Robb Wolf.
I was going to say,
Rob Wolf mentioned it on your podcast,
whatever that was a few weeks ago or
whatever.
Um,
and it's so fascinating to like when you
read Leviticus,
like without the context of,
you know,
the time and then they were living in,
um,
like it,
a lot of it just seemed.
I remember whenever we read be reading
this at home,
you know,
as a family,
like there was just so much of it that
seem like incredibly tedious and like,
what are we supposed to be getting out
of this?
Like I don't even understand.
So I read this chapter and it was so,
like incredible talking about like
Jewish,
the rules about washing your hands,
which is of course the simplest and most
effective form of a hygiene and prevent
preventing pathogens and infectious
disease.
Anyway,
so like super fascinating like how,
how many of those laws make sense like
what you were allowed to eat and what
you weren't allowed to eat because um,
because of um,
not eating pigs,
it was all sorts of parasites,
right?
And then not eating like cats because
cats eat,
like rodents will also carry anyway,
but it's like it's super,
there's so much detail in there and it
was,
it's incredibly fascinating.
So like there's,
when you think about just the history of
humanity and how this book has shaped
people's lives for so long,
it's,
it's really,
uh,
it's really fascinating.
Well,
it is an amazing piece of historical
literature and it's amazing that so many
people have,
not to use the term but use it as
gospel.
I mean,
it's the right term,
right?
And Pat,
I always feel strange whenever I read
it,
whenever I read it,
I feel strange.
So thinking about all the momentum and
all the history that has been altered by
these words and by the application of
these words and your own history when
your own life was essentially guided by
the application of the interpretation of
these words that were thousands of years
old.
I mean,
that is bizarre.
But then what's even more bizarre to me
is that twitter's would snapshot of it
is that interacting with people through
online was this open forum exchange of
ideas.
And especially in twitter where it says
140 character limit.
Yeah,
that's it.
It really bugs me that twitter gets such
a bad rap
because it has saved your life.
You should have a teacher.
This is twitter saved my life.
I,
I think I might actually do that.
Actually.
I went to twitter actually a year ago
and I'm going next week to um,
I didn't drain their trust and safety
council.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That's always sounds so orwellian to me.
Then I found out some of the people that
are on it and they're full of shit.
There's a lot of bs,
social justice warrior nonsense going on
in that
I'm not,
I'm definitely not on the censorship or
you know,
trying to like stop people like shadow
banning people and I just don't know
enough about all of that stuff,
but obviously like I'm definitely on the
side of,
of.
I mean I want people to be able to
control their experiences on twitter of
course.
So I mean you should be able to like,
um,
definitely be able to block people and
meet people and all that stuff.
That's all well and good.
Right?
That's what I mean.
Like,
so you should control your experience.
Been like trying to stop people from.
Because obviously somebody when it's,
when it's criminal,
when people threatening and it's
violence and threats of violence,
I think that of course should be
illegal.
It's illegal,
shouldn't be allowed on the platform,
but I agree.
And harassment,
if you're harassing people or trying to
get people to harass people like
soliciting harassment to others.
Like,
Hey,
let's go.
Go after Megan.
She doesn't believe in the gods word
anymore.
Let's go get her.
Like those kinds of Oregon using the
platform for any sort of a fucked up way
like that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but I'm obviously much more on the side
of the importance of the marketplace of
ideas and being able to do everything.
Absolutely.
Because people.
So many people,
we.
We come to these,
we come to bat ideas in so many
different ways.
Sometimes we argue ourselves there.
Sometimes we're influenced by other
people,
but the way out of it isn't to pretend
or try to push it out of the public
sphere.
It's to engage it,
to shed light on it and to publicly
argue against it so that other people
who might be tempted or starting to go
down that path will understand.
In other words,
we need to have people who can
articulate and defend good principles
and to argue against bad ones so that
the good ones will rise to the top.
Absolutely.
I mean that's everything.
That's human discourse in general and
that's one of the main problems with
really rigid ideologies that there's no
room for that and then you just like,
it's God's word and this is it and you
just have to trust it.
And there's baby dinosaurs on the Ark
and just kind of go,
okay.
And because of that,
that,
like,
I have a friend who's Mormon and she was
Mormon for a long time and then she,
they just sort of drifted away.
They decided it was kind of silly and
then they read into the church and they
started like,
how did this get started?
And they just decided maybe we should
spend some time away.
And so they eventually left.
And one of the things that she said that
was really fascinating,
she said,
um,
I'm really susceptible to like,
like someone who's a bullshit artist.
So like she's like,
I'm easily influenced,
like too much.
So she's like growing up in this
fundamental environment is
fundamentalist,
but where you don't question anything
and you just go along with the word,
she goes,
it leaves me really vulnerable to like
being influenced.
And I was like,
wow,
that is fascinating.
She's like,
I'm really gullible.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's like her,
her structure of how she,
her questioning muscles were like wobbly
and we can atrophy.
They just didn't have any pep to them.
That's exactly the word I use also about
the decision making because if somebody
else was always making the decisions,
if you never have to,
like the is already there for you.
You don't have to figure it out for
yourself.
So on both of those friends,
like when after my sister and I left,
it was this sort of like more or less
constant,
you know,
processing and asking these questions.
So like I would have these.
So for instance,
uh,
like back to gay people after we left,
right?
So,
uh,
I got this guy wrote an open letter,
like he'd been somebody that I sparred
with on twitter quite a bit,
um,
and threaten to pick it but never
actually did.
He wrote an open letter after a in my
sister and I published this statement
essentially just the short explanation
that you know,
we had left and that we regretted
hurting people.
And that,
uh,
we were trying to find a better way to
live basically just because we'd been so
public at the church,
it seemed like we had to,
it,
it seemed like.
And also it's complicated,
but anyway,
so we did this,
he wrote this open letter and response
and invited us to church over at
Hollywood United Methodist Church.
And He,
this guy,
he was gay.
He is gay and Church Goer.
Yes.
Yeah.
And how's he working out?
Reconcile.
Go stuff.
I was going to say,
so you,
you said,
um,
you know earlier,
like just the accepting like whatever
you find in the Bible,
so you therefore you have to accept it
and just go along with it no matter what
evidence or whatever seems to contradict
it or whatever.
I was gonna say like I encountered
people for the first time,
including,
uh,
I'm actually,
I'm actually not sure how he reconciles.
I think it has to do with the love of
Jesus and,
and you know,
grace and you know,
just that's the Old Testament and
whatever.
I'm not exactly New Testament refers.
It does homosexual.
Yeah.
So I honestly don't really know a la La,
La,
I'm not listening.
Well,
so that's what I was going to say.
Like I remember encountering for the
first time Christians who were willing
to say like,
yeah,
I know the Bible says that,
but I think that applied at a different
time or I just don't believe that.
Well,
like I know more than one that has a,
an old testament bible quote tattoo.
Like,
Hey,
you got to read the whole book man.
So
God,
I'm really into what you're saying.
Like,
no,
you're not even listening,
but like that,
like it's,
it's honest,
right?
Like,
to be able to say like,
yes,
I,
I think this is good and to,
but to have the wherewithal to say like,
yeah,
this,
this is good and this is wrong.
There's a Bible verse actually that
says,
Hey,
the evil and love the good.
And I love that.
I mean,
and I don't want to say,
Hey,
I'm talking about,
I'm not never,
it's never about,
for me it's about people.
It's about ideas.
Like I think there are a lot of bad
ideas.
Uh,
and so I try to,
well anyways,
there are a lot about ideas and there's
a lot of people that get defined by bad
ideas and I think in that,
in that way,
the Bible is a lot like people in that
you could take a really good person who
does something stupid,
does something wrong,
doesn't do bad,
and it doesn't mean they're a bad pr.
You can't say like,
you are this time you ran this red light
and hit that car or you are this time
where you,
whatever,
whatever you did that you shouldn't have
done,
that you may have done impulsively or
for whatever reason that doesn't
necessarily define you.
It's a moment in your life.
But we love to find moments like that
and say,
that's you,
tiger woods.
That is you.
You are bad.
I don't like you now.
I hate you.
Like no matter what you do in the
future,
you will be defined by this moment that
you got drunk and drove a car.
Whatever the fuck it is.
It is.
It's,
it's
so frustrating.
And you know now like,
like we,
we,
the tendency now on.
Did you read Jon Ronson's book?
Yes.
You did.
I hear do.
Yeah.
The.
So you've been publicly shamed like
that,
that tendency that too.
Well,
and my family like this,
this,
it's,
it was incredibly judgmental like even
within the church and became even more
so towards the end of,
you know,
before my sister and I left where like
everything,
this is the way that my sister and I
started talking about it after we left,
I was like,
it's like everything that looks bad is
bad and everything that looks good is
also bad.
Like you once you,
if you can,
if you identify a person as some kind of
troublemaker or you know,
you,
you can just read into the worst
intentions and motives when it's just as
likely that it's,
it isn't that like to generalize the
worst.
Oh,
sorry,
sorry.
It's getting under your jaw.
And so sorry.
Sorry,
sorry.
That's okay.
I kind of talked a little bit soft to
sometimes,
but you just don't want to generalize
the worst about people and and make it
make that their entire identity
and there's a tendency to do that with
people that are also there.
There are terrified of scrutiny coming
their way.
So what they do is they cast it all out
on others instead of looking internally,
sort of looking at their own actions and
the blue,
they looked at find a fault in a person
and then that is their main focus and
you see people doing that.
That is why tabloid journalism is so
fascinating.
You go to the supermarket and you know,
you know Matt Lauer's doing cocaine.
Oh look at that.
You know,
like it's like right there in front of
you whether or not it's real,
who knows?
But it's like,
I want to see how he got caught.
What did he do wrong?
What this person is doing,
drugs or whatever.
Whatever anybody's doing,
she's leaving him for her.
She's a lesbian and this,
all this stuff that we love.
When someone is someone did something
bad,
then everybody's watching it.
We love it because we all know that this
creepy shit that we've done that if
somebody found it and then everybody
started talking about,
you'd be horrified.
So when you see someone getting caught
publicly shamed and then this giant pile
on,
it's very attractive to us in some weird
way and almost cathartic and almost a
relief that it's not us,
you know,
but it's so dangerous,
right?
Because it is when,
when you make it,
when the penalty for speaking up and
possibly miss stepping in these various
lists and I don't the whole idea of like
microaggressions,
like I feel like fundamentally like it's
this like,
and I understand like I'm not saying
like I think it's really important.
Like I said this so many times,
like how we talk to people,
like it matters how you talk to people,
but if we're always looking for,
for offense,
we're going to find it.
And so,
but so the problem is when people say
something maybe not quite an exactly the
right way or they like the way that we
punish people when we make the penalties
so high,
you know,
for it.
So just to go back to John's John
Ronson's book that Justine Sacco,
she tasteless joke on twitter to her 170
followers or whatever,
and then it blows up and her entire life
is over.
People don't know the story.
What do you remember the joke?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm going to South Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that turned her life inside out.
Right?
And I don't mean to say like,
I'm not saying like,
I'm just saying that there has to be
more to get biblical grace.
Like there's,
there's this,
uh,
there's this writer that I love
actually.
And she says that,
uh,
the language of public discourse has
lost,
uh,
the house she put it.
It's public discourse has lost the
language of generosity like,
and that I think that's really,
it's really terrible.
But like so when you make the cost of
misspeaking or,
or have have maybe not saying things in
exactly the right way,
like we make that cost so high.
What it does is it pushes out moderates
and what you end up with people on both,
you know,
two ends of these extremes and they are
the only ones talking and then it just,
it just again reinforces this,
this,
you know,
calcification and us them and tribalism
and,
and it's,
it's,
it's dangerous.
I think you're 100 percent right.
I also think there's something that's
going on where when you see someone do
something really stupid like Kathy
Griffin holding up ahead of Donald
Trump,
I think we realized that in our worst
day with our worst thought process,
worse circumstances that could easily be
us in the worst.
If you grew up in a fucked up way or you
have some imbalance in your personal
life or maybe have some chemical
imbalance or you're depressed or,
and then you make a poor judgement call
or you get reinforced by other people
around you that are fools as well.
The next thing you know,
you're doing something dumb and that is,
that's why we like watching people
balance do handstands on the top of
buildings because we know that we've
taken risks.
We know we've done something stupid.
You can identify those aspects of human
behavior and the other folks and when
they're doing something particularly
terrible,
there's a certain amount of relief that
it's not you and there's a certain
amount of fascination of how will this
play out and a certainly how is this
person going to recover from this to all
that stuff is very,
very intoxicating to us as these tribal
animals that lived together and
understand how valuable it is to have
the love and support of your peers and
then that hate is so dangerous.
The ostracizing,
ostracizing of the person from the
group,
the alienation of them from the social
community,
the,
the knowledge that they have,
that people are talking about them all
the time in an evil way.
Kathy Griffin,
she's on American genius,
is going to burn in hell and all this.
That is going to be just eating away at
our and we know it and it's one of the
reasons why we like to concentrate on
it.
There's a certain amount of weird sort
of voyeurism that's involved in any,
any sort of a public misstep that people
have and then the pylon by in a lot of
people are just very,
very unhappy with their lives.
And so when someone else does something
screwed up that they can take away some
of the focus of their own missteps and
focus it on this person and,
and throw rocks.
And there's also just the sense of have
I mean righteousness,
right?
The self righteousness,
the,
the.
Um,
and this is why there's a UGC.
Sarah Silvermans new netflix special.
I haven't seen it yet.
Uh,
so she gets to a point and she's talking
about like going out to a picket at
Westboro picket and wow.
And I actually had seen,
she talked about this on Bill Maher a
few years ago too.
And I just remember like,
I,
I knew her as this,
like I didn't really.
I of course know her anything specific
except for her,
her comedy.
She seemed kind of just kind of loud and
a little.
I don't know,
she'd say things that would always make
me cringe.
Like,
just very,
like very blunt,
you listened to her comedy while you're
in the church.
Sure.
Little like,
you know,
like they're,
they're really like,
they're constantly,
they call themselves,
they're the watchers,
right?
So they are looking around the landscape
and seeing like how the word of God
applies to all these people.
They have to in order to,
to comment on what's going on.
They have to know what's going on.
So what people are saying and,
and the trends and,
and,
and things.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
so I,
when I saw her on del Mar,
I expected her to be,
I dunno,
like hostile and,
and whatever about the church when we
started talking about them.
Well,
what she said,
what she said was,
at least on the,
on the special,
the way she put it was I am them like
she went out and was talking to members
of my family and you know,
she said we have to see them as human.
And she was kind to them on the picket
line,
like told her,
she said,
I told the duty joke or whatever,
you know,
trying and the picket or I guess one of
my cousins or something like snickered,
you know,
when she,
when she makes this joke,
uh,
we have to see them as human and then
maybe they'll start to see us as human.
And the way she put it on the,
on the Netflix special was that I am.
Then I am the product of my experiences.
And so are they.
And the only way you can change those
things as to add to the,
those experiences like to introduce like
David did on twitter with me and my
husband.
Like introduce these ideas in ways that,
that people can actually hear them and
be moved by them.
Yeah.
We love to categorize people into these
rigid boxes that are unchangeable and
that you are this person.
You will always be this person.
You are my enemy and you think this and
you think that and you're a dirty
liberal and you're a disgusting
Republican.
And we have these weird ideological
boxes that we love to shove people into.
That's a perfect example of that.
I mean,
if they were little kids and they grew
up in that church and they're seven
years old,
do we really believe that they would
have the wherewithal and the
understanding of the full spectrum of
human behavior to say that this is wrong
and that we shouldn't be protesting at
this gay person's funeral and we
shouldn't be holding up these signs and
say God hates fags because God hates
fags or not.
Like,
are you right
grandpa?
Like who would have the mind?
What's incredibly brave is that you deep
into your twenties have this revelation
and then have the courage to escape.
And so I want to get back to that.
Like what was your job like?
What did,
what was the first job you got a.
So I didn't get a job immediately.
I thought I had to.
I thought I have to be responsible.
Like of course I'm with my sister.
Like we had some money saved,
just we lived at home.
We didn't have a lot of expenses,
like we used our money to travel across
the country picketing,
but we still,
we still had some money awareness.
We have to get out there and piss people
off.
Oh wait.
I didn't always.
I thought it was the greatest.
Like I thought like it was always
excited.
Like,
oh,
are you going on this picket shape?
Yeah,
I'm going to Los Angeles.
It was just like a part of life.
You guys used to picket scientology
Elidel and we're doing it in clearwater
wants to super boring.
Like there was nobody out there.
You got to rank the pickets by like,
I don't know.
George W dot Bush's second inauguration
was like insane and there's like
scientology post nine slash 11.
Most of them are really rough to hold up
those signs.
Yeah.
Especially we had a sign that said thank
God for nine slash 11.
Oh God damn it.
And it was like we were stationed at the
intersection of these three streets and
they were blocked off for the parade.
So like he finishes his inauguration
speech and this huge crowd of people,
like hundreds of that whatever.
How many thousands of people like flood
down this thing and then they're stuck
in this,
in this intersection waiting to go right
past us on the sidewalk.
And so there was this a new,
they're seeing this like thank God for
nine slash 11 and it was right after the
tsunami to a.
So my mom had a son was holding the
thank God for the tsunamis or whatever
and I'm like,
so people are just enraged by the time
they actually got to us.
So like we're standing like right at the
edge of these barricades,
like so on the other side is the parade
route.
And so like,
you know,
people were like jumping,
like some guy jumped on my back on one
another,
like stealing signs and like jumped on
your back.
Yeah,
like,
so I'm,
I was like leaning over the barricade so
he couldn't steal my sign.
Sorry,
I'm not getting away from the mic.
And uh,
so like one of my cousins actually like
gave his science to another church
member and then it was like standing on
top of a Trashcan,
like going,
come on,
you guys like just,
just don't worry about them.
They're not worth it.
Like with my cousin who was just because
it was so it got so physical,
like you know,
people and like the cops saying you guys
aren't worth it.
He was trying to.
Yeah,
pretending he was one.
exactly.
Oh Wow.
Yeah,
that one got pretty.
pretty.
Got Pretty Dicey.
But get violent guy who jumped on your
back like what did he do?
So I will,
I'm holding my sons and I'm like,
like I've talked myself into this
barricade.
So like there's nothing else he can do.
So He.
And there was like,
there was,
I should also say there were cops just
on the other side of the barricade just
like,
like every five feet there was a cop,
I think there was.
So there was like maybe 14,000 cops in
DC that exercise first integration after
nine slash 11.
So anyway,
but,
so,
I mean the cops were mostly just
standing there like I look over and the
guy gets off and I'm like,
my,
my brother is standing next to me who's
seven or eight,
eight years.
He would have been like early twenties
and uh,
um,
this I see.
And when he jumped over the barricade
because the way people were coming after
us and this cop like pulls out a,
uh,
you know,
club to and making us get back over the
bar,
like jump back over on the other side,
like with these people who were,
and not really doing anything but it,
it would you expect the cops to risk
their lives even though you're obviously
provoking people.
I mean you're obviously putting yourself
in a situation where you're saying
something incredibly insulting and just
devastating to all these people that
lost friends or loved ones on nine slash
11 or in the tsunami or,
or have family members that are gay.
I mean,
did you guys really expect the cops are
going to take the beating for you or the
cops are going to get involved?
For sure.
I thought that he was like,
it's their job,
right?
They did.
You would never do what you did then.
Right?
Like,
what if,
what if someone passed some sort of a
loss and listen to you guys know what
you're in for.
We have no desire to help you.
There'll be no police presence.
Would you still protest?
Well,
we did that and that some cops did
respond that way.
There'll be no police presence
whatsoever.
And some where was that at?
Can't remember it.
But it happened more than once a month.
Yeah,
for sure.
And like sometimes the cops would,
we'd say we're going to come to protest
this,
you know,
something.
And they would say,
you know,
you can come,
but you can't hold that sign or you
can't tell you step on the flag or
whatever.
Sometimes they'll tell us in advance.
Sometimes they wait until we got this
step on the flag.
Yeah.
Like we desecrating the flag was a big,
uh,
we saw it as an idol and you know,
the American flags and I don't actually,
my mom got arrested.
I had a,
we were in Nebraska and um,
uh,
my little brother that were protesting a
soldier's funeral and we were like far
away from the church,
but there was a group of people on the
other side of the street and they were
all holding American flags all the way
from,
from the road all the way up this,
you know,
the long entry to the,
to the church.
So we were quite far away and my brother
was nine years old at the time and he
did what he always did,
which was a,
you know,
put down,
lay the American flag on the ground and
stand on top of it and hold a picket
sign.
And within like a couple of minutes,
uh,
like nine cops showed up and started
talking about arresting my mother for
flag mutilation and contributing to the
delinquency of a minor.
And uh,
so before they do the arrest,
you know,
again,
my mom and my uncle were both there and
they are both lawyers and my uncle's
like a Johnson versus Texas Supreme
Court said in that case that,
uh,
you can even,
you can utilize,
not only can you mutilate a flag,
you can even burn it.
And uh,
and that's perfectly lawful.
And one of the cops was like,
we're not in Texas,
we're in Nebraska.
So like this is obviously a supreme
court case.
So it's.
And he said Supreme Court has
jurisdiction all over the country.
So in other words,
I guess what I'm saying,
it's like the,
the way that sometimes the,
they did,
sometimes they were really good cops who
did their job more super professional
and didn't let their beliefs about our
religious beliefs or their,
what they thought about our message,
get in the way of them doing their job.
But sometimes they did,
sometimes they were threatened to
arrest,
you know,
my,
our parents,
if they brought children,
they would take their children away from
them,
you know,
things like that.
But,
but we absolutely expected them to do
their job like that.
That was,
and this is the supreme court.
Yeah.
I mean,
I know you're not justifying it,
but it's
from the point of view of something like
me,
someone like me,
I,
I would say don't bring any cops there.
No.
If you,
if you start that kind of shit at a
funeral or for a soldier and a bunch of
people come by and beat your ass,
well then don't do that again because
you're pissing people off and you're
hurting their feelings and you're
dealing with someone who's already
emotionally scarred.
Those cops need to be out there stopping
robberies and you know,
breaking and entering into people's
houses and car jackings and that's what
they're supposed to be doing.
They're not supposed to be like helping
out people who are intentionally
provoking and emotionally disturbing
people.
Right.
But I mean,
so obviously from the treasury
perspective,
it's like this,
it's a sincerely held religious beliefs
and the first amendment like what good
is the first amendment like this?
Obviously this,
but it's not a first amendment issue
like the car because the.
No one in an official position is saying
you cannot speak
well.
So compare that to like the campus,
what's going on on these campuses,
right where,
sorry,
you think that the cops shouldn't be
there to protect those people there?
They're provoking people and making them
angry.
Well,
it's a different sort of a scenario.
Um,
I think the cops should definitely be
there to prevent violence on campus for
several reasons.
One reason because I think you're
dealing with very young,
very impressionable people who make very
poor choices and feel justified because
they're around a bunch of people that
also have likeminded ideas,
a lot of peer pressure,
a lot of diffusion of responsibility
that comes from these massive groups of
people that are acting and the mob
mentality that comes along with that.
I think it's very,
very important to protect them from
themselves and it's a hot button issue.
I think protesting at a soldier's
funeral is just gross.
I agree with you.
I know you do.
I mean,
but I'm just saying I don't think the
cops have a responsibility to save you
from being gross.
Yeah.
I just,
I,
I don't know,
I mean obviously this was a supreme
court case.
It became a.
Did you know that,
that this was a case where we were sued
by the church?
Yeah,
I do remember that.
And how did that play out?
Uh,
it,
it went the first,
they,
they want a 10 point $9 million dollar
verdict against us at the trial court
and then it was reversed at the appeals
court and the Supreme Court said eight
to one.
They have the constitutional right for
them to do this.
This is their religious beliefs.
They have a right.
Especially because,
I mean sometimes I will say like I
described to you that very first picket
soldier's funeral picket that I went to
that was very close quarters,
you know,
we were right up on top of them,
like if we had chosen to sing or when
you know,
that,
they would have heard us,
but in a lot of instances we were way
far,
far away.
Like in that in the instance that went
to the supreme court,
they were more than a thousand feet
away.
There was like a hill that the family
didn't see church members,
you know,
things like that.
There was a.
So I mean they have a right to do it
will the church and we
have a right to do it,
say horrible things about someone who
just died or someone who lost a son or a
daughter and war.
Yeah,
I think obviously I don't think it's
terrible that they do do it and that was
actually one of the things,
you know before my sister and I left,
that was one of the.
I wasn't going to hold a sign that I
didn't believe was true and I wasn't
going to go to any more funerals.
Protests were.
But do you think that the police should.
I mean they're,
they're operating on tax dollars and
it's a limited amount of resource.
I mean,
we're taxpayers,
right?
I mean sure you are,
but do you think the resources should go
to get out of the house?
Right?
Yeah.
No,
I know.
But do you think that really the,
the cops,
that's the.
An intelligent and adequate and fair use
of resources to go and protect a bunch
of troublemakers.
So it depends on what,
how you,
how do you feel about the first
amendment?
Like at the,
it's,
it's the principle of the thing rather
than the applications.
Like this is just one application,
like so who's to decide.
That's the whole idea.
Like,
so who,
what we have not interested our
government to decide what opinions are
acceptable and what aren't.
So they don't,
they don't get to.
But it seems like you're organizing
this.
So if you're organizing this sort of
antagonistic display where you know
you're going to hurt dangerous time,
right?
Don't you think you should hire your own
security?
Like why should the police have to be
there to secure you?
Because.
Because this,
it's the law.
They are supposed to protect like the
again,
what,
what good are first amendment rights,
right?
To be able to say it's,
it doesn't protect popular speech,
right?
Because public speeches need protection.
Unpopular speech needs protection.
So it's just again,
it's the,
the police are really there to enforce
laws.
You don't get to punch somebody
go.
So for instance,
like go back to the campus thing for a
second.
You have these people who have announced
we're going to go protest this person.
We're not going to let them speak even
though they've been granted permission
by the,
you know,
everybody like they're going,
they should be able to speak,
right.
We're not going to let them speak
because we don't like their message.
So if the cops know that that's gonna
happen,
like,
so.
So what happens?
Like,
I'm just trying to let them shut it
down.
Um,
but I'm saying I think that's wrong.
I think they should be able,
they should go and like,
so this is what big Vito is,
what it's called,
right?
I think in,
in like the cops can't say,
well obviously this is still back to
like,
it's not.
If the cops say,
well you can't speak because you're
likely to cause a riot or people to,
you know,
some,
some kind of disturbance.
Like they're not allowed to do that
based on like if it's just,
this is religious opinion and we weren't
saying we want you to hurt us,
we're not trying to provoke you to hurt
us.
We're trying to deliver this message
that we think is the truth of God.
Right?
So it wasn't.
There's a difference between like
deliberately provoking and inciting
violence,
like deliberately inciting violence and
what we were doing,
which was,
you know,
trying to proclaim this message that we
thought was the truth.
Our goal wasn't violence.
Like we didn't want violence.
That's why we contacted the cops.
We weren't going to attack them and,
and we didn't want to be attacked.
We just want it to be able to exercise
our rights without fear of without fear
of violence.
That's the principles of,
of our democracy.
Right.
So I'll see what you're saying.
And I think that gets a little weird
when we're talking about people giving
speeches on campus and then having other
people shut down those speeches because
I think that the people who are
protesting have as much.
Right.
Especially if it's in their school,
they have as much right to voice their
concern for this message as the person
does distribute that message and if the
police come along and say we're going to
shut down the distribution of this
message,
most of the time they do it when things
are out of hand.
So an excellent tool for someone who's
trying to silence people is to make sure
that things get out of hand.
I mean is why so that having the cops
present like and,
and letting both sides have their voices
without the ability to resort to
violence.
So this is the whole idea.
Like we would in these letters that
would go out to the cops.
Was that the idea of having a buffer
zone like a.
yes,
we're going,
we want to proclaim our message.
We want you to be out there too.
Like we loved and I honestly,
we loved doing counter protestors were
there because it just brought more
attention to our message.
I understand that,
but I just think that you shouldn't.
Obviously it's not you anymore,
but I just do not think that anybody,
especially from an offensive group like
that,
she'd be able to allocate resources that
are public use will police.
Well.
So we obviously we would make the
decision on,
we didn't make the decision to,
for them to like they decide like,
okay,
well is this likely going to like so
they can either be proactive and set the
buffer zone or be reactive.
Like we're calling the cops because
we're getting punched or whatever and
[inaudible] like they're going to go out
no matter what it was.
We,
when even when they would say we're not
going to protect you were,
we would go.
I mean there were obviously,
there were rare situations where,
uh,
so for instance,
like,
uh,
when Gabby giffords was shot in Arizona,
we had a couple of,
I'm an FBI agent actually end a guy from
the local police department come and say
like,
you shouldn't go.
And because there,
there's a nine year old girl who had
been killed in the church that they were
going to protest her funeral.
Jesus.
And so they said,
I don't think we can protect you like
this,
it's too volatile.
It's too.
Um,
and so in that case we didn't,
we actually didn't go.
That's kind of a chicken shit response
actually as I was going to say,
uh,
like,
so
the thing is,
so I was there during this conversation
and my hurt,
my mom was explaining that we weren't
gonna go,
um,
it actually had more to do with
logistics.
Like we couldn't get there,
like plane tickets
then whatever.
Like we just couldn't get there.
So it was like,
okay,
like that's fine.
Like I hear you,
but like so reasonable.
It's so fascinating to talk to you
because you're such an intelligent,
reasonable person.
It's almost impossible for me to imagine
until I see like the little bit of
resistance to the idea of this being a
first amendment issue and the police
there.
Then you kind of go back to the church.
I could see it boil up inside of you.
Well,
let's just,
we were talking about this a little bit
of I and just the whole,
the importance of discourse in the
marketplace of ideas.
This is one like I like,
again,
I,
I just think it's so important and I
think it's important,
you know,
because obviously my own personal
experience makes me such a believer in
are you've on a journey through free
speech,
but most people will never experience
free speech so you don't even agree with
anymore.
Right?
Yeah.
Which is even more crazy.
So let's get back to your first job.
What was it?
What was the first job?
I worked at a,
um,
very briefly like,
so I should say my sister and I,
we were in,
it was a couple months before I actually
got a job.
Um,
we spent the first month with a cousin
of mine who had left the church a few
years earlier.
She lived really close.
She had left her as well.
Yeah.
So you guys knew some people had made it
out.
Right?
But the thing is,
there's so many.
My sister calls them Mindfox,
right?
So like the thing about people who leave
is that they are demonized more than
anybody else,
even more than gays or Jews or any other
outsider.
It's x members who get the worst,
you hear the worst things about them
because they knew the truth and they
rejected it.
Right.
So I was what came when I thought of
leading,
like the last thing on my mind was that
I could go to an ex member.
I thought you can't trust them,
that people like,
so it's,
it's this,
this whole,
um,
intensely negative instinctive reactions
to those things.
But obviously I overcame it and I
reached out to her a few weeks before we
left and she was amazing,
like within.
I hadn't talked to her in three and a
half years and had said all kinds of
terrible things about her,
um,
after she left.
But,
um,
but she was wonderful and she said like,
within like 30 seconds of like when I,
when she understood that I was planning
to leave,
uh,
I want you to come live with me.
And it was,
it was amazing and so kind.
And so where I lived with her for about
a month,
um,
my sister was still in school,
so she was,
we were traveling back to Kansas to
Topeka.
Sorry.
It's like,
so it's half an hour from my cousin's
house and you know,
four days a week while was still in
school and so we were constantly running
into our family and driving by the
pickets because they pick it everyday in
Topeka several times a day and a like at
the grocery store and on campus.
And so it was just,
we needed to get away so we ended up
going to deadwood,
South Dakota.
Um,
my brother had been a fan of the TV show
and a,
it just seemed like a,
a nice quiet place.
So how many people went with you?
It's you,
your sister and your brother?
No,
it was just,
just you and your sister and sister?
Yeah.
Did anybody else join you?
After awhile?
I have a brother who left about a year
and a half after my sister and I did and
I have another brother who left about
eight years before I did.
Wow.
So another seven.
There's 11 kids.
So seven are still at home and four of
us are out.
Do you talk to them?
Yeah,
the people who are out.
Yeah.
What about the people that are in?
No,
they won't have anything to do with us.
They're just like,
I talked to your mom.
No,
no.
Uh,
sh.
They,
the thing is like,
so back to twitter,
like that's how I know what are,
what they're up to.
Like I said,
I see photos like they post photos,
like I'm going to,
watching my little brother grow up on
their photos on twitter and see what my
parents wanted.
It's awful.
I mean it's,
it's,
I'm glad.
I'm so glad to be living now and not,
you know,
before social media where I can actually
see these things and,
and know what they're up to and a little
bit about how they're going to reach
out.
I do.
You do.
I mean,
I do on twitter,
you know,
there's this great about twitter.
Um,
sometimes like I have,
they blocked me on my main account.
Not all of them,
but a lot of them to mom blocked you.
She actually created,
she,
she got kicked off of twitter at one
[inaudible] point,
so she had to create a new account.
So she didn't block me under new account
yet.
Um,
but blocked you in her own account.
Yeah.
Wow.
Deep.
Yeah.
Your mom blogs you on twitter.
That's
when you look and you see that you're
blocked.
What is that?
What does that lump in your throat like,
just want you to imagine like,
I can't believe it's so hard to think
back to like I was incredibly close with
my mom and I,
I love her and I miss her.
Like I used to make coffee for her every
morning and like you go on walks
together and we spoke to her.
Um,
well actually I,
I saw her to pick it a little over a
year ago.
She didn't,
she didn't say anything to me.
She didn't even talk to,
you know,
she,
she couldn't like baby that came from
her body.
Loved you and raise you.
She can like,
it's,
it's so like when I think about like
when I was at the church,
and this is one of the hardest things to
articulate.
I mean to the feeling of like when
somebody leaves,
like there is no interaction.
So some people would ask like,
well what if you saw her at such a
place,
you know,
wherever at the grocery store,
whatever.
Like what,
what would you say?
They would ask me this while I was still
at the church and it's so it's like a I,
the only thing I can compare it to is
like,
it's like dividing by zero.
Like the situation does not exist.
Like there's nothing there.
The idea of trying to talk to her,
it is impossible.
Right.
And,
and that's the Colt.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's the Jehovah's Witnesses.
They call it a dis.
Fellowshipping,
right.
They all have an excommunication ecology
houses.
They all have it.
It's one of the ways they control people
to fear of alienation and becoming like
them.
Yeah,
exactly.
So they'll talk to gay people,
they'll talk to people with rainbow
shirts arm,
they'll talk to ex soldiers,
they'll talk to those people,
they won't talk to you.
Right.
That's insane.
But this is one of your mana acid.
When
I'm.
One of the great things about twitter
and the Internet in general is that it's
a thing where.
So like obviously like my little
brothers for instance,
like they are,
you know,
hearing all this bad stuff about,
my sister and me,
anybody who leaves,
they,
they'll hear bad things about us.
But the good thing about the internet is
that they can go on,
they can go to my twitter account and
see what I'm actually saying.
So I'm still,
I go through these phases where like I,
I,
I will tweet and then I get like I
can't,
I just like the,
the,
the fear of judgment I guess from my
family and I just,
I just choose to focus on other things
and not post things on twitter but like
I follow them on this other account that
I created.
It's not blocked.
Right.
And it's just WBC accounts.
So like I see things that they say and
like doctrines that I now believe are
unscriptural and so like I will tweet
them,
you know,
versus like this contradicts you.
Like and try to like basically doing
what I was doing for them now against
them like just in this,
in these instances.
And so there is some engagement a little
bit with my family on twitter because
especially because of any like anything
that I do publicly,
so maybe something about this,
I dunno,
but like when my ted talk came out,
there was a couple of articles and like
people were tweeting it a lot and,
and uh,
so my uncle and my aunt both were
tweeting,
tweeting me and tweeting about me and so
I was,
you know,
we're having this party I guess like
just going back and forth about these,
these Bible verses and debating.
And so all of that stuff is,
it's,
I,
I hope at some point hopefully we'll
have,
we'll have some effect and in some ways
it already has.
So like the day that I left,
there was a we're going to get to that
job sometimes worry about
the day that I left my,
one of my cousins came into my bedroom
while I was crying and packing.
And I was asking like,
just very calmly,
like,
this is my best.
My best friend,
she was a year older than me,
is a year older than.
And she's asked me why we're leaving and
I'm describing a lot of things.
And one of the two I described
specifically two signs,
uh,
one of them was the death penalty for
fags and another one was fags can't
repent.
And uh,
she sent me a message the next morning
and I was describing versus that I
thought,
you know,
contradicted those two signs.
And uh,
the following morning she sent me a
message,
a text message super early in the
morning,
just like a,
just chewing me out basically like that,
that I know that,
that leviticus and Romans one like the
death penalty.
Like there's no,
there's,
you have no argument.
Like,
so.
So what's your really your problem?
And um,
so,
and then for a while after I left,
like those signs were like everywhere,
like she's holding,
my cousin changes her profile picture on
twitter to her holding those two signs,
like screaming into the camera and like
one of the elders like making a snow
angel with those two signs.
And it's like,
so they're just like doubling down on
this.
Right.
And so this goes on,
it's like during this time,
like I'm talking about it in like giving
a few interviews,
like talking about it.
They're like on twitter a little bit.
I'm like reiterating the verses that
contradict them.
And then like after more than two years,
like I wake up one morning and I
checked,
you know,
I'm checking their twitters and uh,
there was a blog post and they said,
uh,
about that fags can't repent sign.
And I was like,
oh my God,
it's like open the blog post and it's a
for the first time ever they had
publicly disavowed assign and using the
same Bible verses that I had been.
And I know that's just like a very small
point in the grand scheme of things.
Right.
But the reason that's critical
reasoning,
but like,
so this is,
this is the goal,
right?
So like to,
knowing this is what I do know the story
behind it.
I don't,
I don't.
It was after my,
my brother left.
So I don't really know,
you know,
nobody who's left since then.
I also have,
I have to,
to actually have my cousins have left
since then also.
Um,
but none of them have any understanding
of,
of what happened.
So I don't know,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to take credit.
I should also say like,
well,
it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
It just changes.
Possible gets into their head that what
they're doing.
It's not in any way the teachings of
Christ.
Right.
I mean like the thing is like some,
some of it is,
some of it is.
Yeah.
But like there's the huge bag stuff will
like.
So it's so crazy because like this is
something that I didn't realize until
after we left also.
But like,
um,
we thought,
remember I told you about love thy
neighbor,
like they have a site in love.
Thy Neighbor equals rebuke,
right?
Because that's in leviticus 19.
That's how it describes,
you know,
loves warning your neighbor when you see
them sending.
So they don't have an opportunity to
repent,
but the one time.
So in the New Testament,
uh,
Jesus is talking with this guy and the
guy says like,
hi,
do I inherit eternal life?
And he says,
well,
Jesus is what is,
what does the scripture say?
And he says to love God and to love your
neighbor.
And he says,
you're right.
He says,
and who is my neighbor?
And Jesus tells a story of the Good
Samaritan.
So it's like this.
Do you know the story?
Um,
how's it go?
It's,
um,
so this man says this man falls among
thieves and they beat him and leave him
half dead.
The beat him until he's half dead or
whatever,
and you know,
steal his clothes and,
and leave them there.
And then it says a,
a priest goes and sees the man and he
crosses the street and walk by on the
other side.
And then Levi,
who's also like dealing with the things
of God,
right?
Um,
he goes,
does this same thing,
crosses and,
and goes on,
goes on his way.
It doesn't help them.
And then the Samaritan stops and binds
up his wounds and puts them on his own.
So it's puts them on his own beast and
taking them to an end and gives the
innkeeper money to take care of him and
says anything that you spend more than
this,
I'm going to,
I'll pay you back when I,
when I come again.
So he's like actually practically taken
care of him.
So Jesus says,
and who do you think?
Which,
which of these was neighbor to the man
who fell among thieves.
And he said he who has mercy on him.
So in other words,
what I'm saying is we reduced loving our
neighbor to preaching,
to picketing,
to putting words on signs and going out
and publishing them.
That's what we thought loving our
neighbor was.
But the one time,
the example that Jesus gives is not
preaching like they,
they didn't go.
Like the Samaritan didn't go and say
like,
this happened to you because you're a
senator.
Repent.
He went and helped them.
And so like,
where was that on our picket signs were
why?
Like why didn't.
Exactly,
exactly like why,
why didn't we,
why didn't we make that an issue for
ourselves?
Like a primary part of our theology.
And why didn't we encourage others to do
it too.
Anyway,
so that again,
this is something that I didn't realize
until after I did it was I was talking
to a couple of Christian friends of mine
who,
who pointed that out.
And I was like,
I cannot believe I missed that.
Like all those years like,
and what's crazy is like the,
in,
in the story,
the priest and the Levi to the people
who are like dealing with the things of
God.
Right?
So they're presumably preaching.
It's not enough.
That's not,
that's not the fulfillment of that.
Yeah.
So anyway,
there's like so many of these things
that I just couldn't see when I was at
the church because again,
you're,
you're in this,
it's kind of an echo chamber.
Like clearly we had access to the
outside world and we're having these
discussions.
But the problem with that discussion is
that in a lot of cases people just
didn't understand what our theology
actually was.
How we actually thought,
which is why,
you know,
David Habit Ball,
making this,
you know,
judicious,
like the fact that this was an ongoing
conversation that he really got into the
nuances of our theology and could really
understand where I was coming from to be
able to make the point in a way that I
could understand.
And that's,
I mean,
I'm kind of in a position to do that
with my family now.
Anybody,
any of us who leaves and who
understands,
you know,
can,
can try to push back in a way that's a
lot more effective than people who just
don't understand where they're,
where they're coming from.
So you get this job.
Yes.
I go to deadwood.
My sister and I got a dead one.
And uh,
we were only going to be there for a
month and then we're going to go back
and grace was going to go to school and
then I was going to get a job.
Um,
and then I was in deadwood for a couple
of weeks and I was like,
I could,
I the idea of going back to Kansas and
like being back in the shadow of the
church and seeing our family all the
time and like seeing them and not like
it's,
it's constantly being face to face with
rejection and the people that we love
the most and like the idea of going back
to that environment,
like I,
my cousin was wonderful and I love her
dearly,
like I just couldn't go back there.
So like the day before we're supposed to
leave deadwood,
a grace decided to try out for a play
there and uh,
an agreed to stay with me.
So he changed like all of her classes to
be online and anyway,
so we're in,
we're staying with Jehovah's Witnesses,
which we didn't know that when we booked
it,
it was an airbnb.
My first,
our first airbnb is a beautiful old
house in the black hills.
And um,
um,
so yeah,
like they,
they thought at first when they realized
what was happening,
like who we were,
we started having these conversations
and then we find out they're Jehovah's
Witnesses and they thought at first that
we might be disfellowshipped witnesses
before they realized that was,
we were at the church anyway,
so it was just like,
this is insane conversations about,
um,
you know,
doctrine and theology and interpretation
and,
and it was just so mind blowing to see
that there were other ways of
understanding these texts that are
consistent with the text,
but totally different than we
understood.
Anyway,
the husband,
Dustin is co,
owns a marketing company in deadwood,
so I took a job there part time.
So what is your process or what's the
journey from leaving the church going to
deadwood,
the men becoming sort of a self
proclaimed atheist.
Like how do you,
how do you completely remove yourself
from the shackles of audiology or did
you know?
So it's,
it's,
um,
it's definitely,
uh,
I didn't want to do.
I don't,
I don't think it's possible.
It's not like a switch flips and you're
just,
everything that you knew is gone.
You're obviously very rational.
Yeah.
So it was like each,
each time we'd be presented with a
situation that,
that uh,
so like gay people or Jewish people or
these like Jehovah's Witnesses,
it was obviously I had the instinctive
responses to their ideas.
Um,
and so,
but each time I would feel,
feel something.
It would,
I would just ask myself these questions,
you know,
what am I feeling,
why am I feeling it?
Is this just instinctive?
What is the evidence like?
Does what makes sense?
Like it's sort of like having to,
to,
to try to reconstruct,
like,
like actually look at the evidence
again,
like starting from scratch basically a
in a lot
of ways.
So,
so each time we're presented with these
situations like,
you know,
it's because obviously like there's all
these like.
So for instance,
gay people like that actually didn't
take that long to change.
Like,
because I,
I had met a lot of gay people like while
I was at the church and,
and they,
after we left and you know,
we're talking to them and I'm like,
you know,
I,
I thought I was doing the right thing
and,
and I'm sorry,
like I didn't,
I didn't intend to hurt to hurt you or
to say hurtful things about you.
Like I thought I thought it was the
truth and now I don't know what the
truth is.
I don't know.
I don't know what I believe.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Um,
and like people,
I mean they responded to that.
I mean like they were really
understanding and empathetic in a way
that I never imagined people would be
like,
given how,
I don't know if you've seen like a,
it's really hard for me to still to go
back and watch some of those videos
because it's so,
it's,
I know exactly where I was coming from
at the time.
But it's so like the arrogance and the
condescension and the certainty that we
were right.
And now,
of course,
knowing like all the reasons why I don't
believe those things,
it's a very strange,
strange dynamic.
But anyway,
so like the fact that people were
understanding in spite of that long
history of all those things that I had
said and done at the church,
um,
was,
was overwhelming and,
and,
and wonderful.
Um,
but anyway,
so like being,
I was basically my sister and I were
basically putting ourselves over and
over.
Um,
we were,
hadn't been in deadwood for very long.
When I got a message from David,
it was on my,
on my birthday and I,
I told him that we had left.
And uh,
you know,
he,
he saw it,
stopped tweeting,
that's,
he knew something was up.
But I had stopped tweeting several
months earlier.
And,
uh,
so he invited us to come to the Jewish
festival,
which was a few weeks later.
It's like end of February or something,
beginning of March.
And uh,
I had protested the delicious festival
like three years earlier and all these
negative associations and feelings about
Jewish people,
but realizing I don't know anything
about Jewish people,
like we've been protesting the synagogue
in Topeka,
like all my life,
but I haven't,
I don't really know what,
like,
other than,
you know,
just generally Jews killed Jesus and
reject him as the savior.
So therefore they're without hope.
But I didn't know really much about
Jewish theology.
I didn't know anything about Jewish
people.
Like I'd never really spent time with
them.
So,
so I wanted to go to the festival,
my sister and I did,
um,
because we wanted to,
we wanted to meet Jewish people and like
do this whole,
it's this examining process like what do
we believe in,
why and what.
And,
and we got so much like light and sort
of wisdom from other people like
learning what they believed and why,
you know.
So.
And then David said,
yeah,
but you have to,
you have to speak at the festival.
And I was like,
no,
this is not happening.
Like I,
I can't,
I cannot imagine facing these people
that I've spent so many years.
I thought I just,
it just seemed impossible and it
terrified me to be coming face to face
with people and,
and I had,
hadn't even been out of the church the
three months yet.
So it was,
it was really scary.
But my sister was like,
we're going,
like,
she,
she knew that we needed to have this
experience of,
of,
of learning about Jewish people and if
the cost was we have to talk about it
fun.
And she still also said later she knew I
would do most of the talking.
So it's like,
okay,
fine.
But so we went and we spoke there and
then I thought,
okay,
that's great.
Now we're gonna like we need to figure
out like grace.
And I kept saying we want to do good
like that.
That had been the motivating principle
of our life was to do good and now we
realize we did so much damage.
And,
and uh,
so anyway,
so we were trying to find a way,
like we didn't know what to do.
Like how,
how do you move forward from there?
And so we,
we just,
we didn't know.
Um,
so we were kind of drifting that whole
first year.
We,
we basically,
I think a month was the longest we spent
anywhere we were um,
you know,
we went to visit x members of the church
who were across the country.
My Dad's family who we never knew
growing up because they were never part
of the church.
So I mean,
like we,
we had seen them,
like they would come visit for a few
hours sometimes or maybe a couple of to
visit even though there for a while.
But then my several years before we
left,
they cut off all contact with his family
there also.
It had been very limited already.
But then spoken to your dad either.
So he spoke to his family?
Yeah,
his,
his parents and his brother.
My,
my grandmother.
I called her,
um,
about a month,
a little over a month after we left,
one of my first nights in deadwood and I
told her we have left and she just
immediately started crying and she said
I had been waiting for this for 30
years.
Like she had my older brother had one of
my older brothers had left since,
since my dad had joined the church,
is what she was saying,
you know,
she,
my dad's parents are so there's,
they're amazing people like his dad is,
it was career air force.
He retired from the,
from the air force.
Um,
and they're,
they're wonderful people and all we
could see of them was,
well,
they're divorced and remarried there.
They're going to hell.
There are a bad influence.
And like,
it what's,
it's,
it's insane to me now to think like my
grandmother has been without her son,
her son for decades and how painful that
must be.
Like I've only been,
it's been four and a half years since I
left.
And what am I going to be doing in 30
years?
Like,
how am I,
what is,
what is the.
And I don't know,
it's a crazy journey that you've been on
for just four and a half years.
It's really insane
work.
When did it
solidify in your head that you were
going to like,
identify or like speak out as a
nonbeliever
this morning?
I mean like,
so I was,
I was actually talking to the same about
this a few months ago.
Like,
because like there's,
there's,
there's part of me that like,
I mean when I said when a lot of a lot
of people here jerk when they hear
atheist and uh,
I don't use that word for myself,
atheist,
I don't know either.
And it's because it entails like it
seems to bring in this idea that you're
so certain your certain,
there's no god,
you mock people who are religious,
you don't like them and all this.
And I,
I,
I don't feel that like,
and I also feel like I am,
I'm open to evidence,
you know,
like I haven't like decided there is no
god.
It's like I just,
I just don't see the evidence and so I
don't believe.
And if there is evidence,
like I want to know,
like,
and again,
I talked to religious people all the
time and I think about theology a lot.
I just,
I can't not like
it also becomes,
there's a,
there's a group mentality involved in
atheism and there's a.
One of the reasons why I was reluctant
to identify as an atheist is that so
many people were asking me to identify
as an atheist.
I'm like,
what do you give a shit?
Why do you want me to come out?
I told you I'm not religious,
but
especially
especially the idea that there cannot be
a god or there cannot be any sort of a
higher power and that after you die,
it just ends.
How do you know?
Right,
exactly.
And that's exactly where I am.
It's not a knowing for certain that
there is no god.
I just don't.
There's so little we know about human
life.
Forget about the idea of possibility of
afterlife or the possibility of what
consciousness is there.
Possibility of what this concept that we
call soul is.
What is,
what is that?
Or forget about psychedelic experiences
and what do they represent and what,
what,
what do they represent when they're
coming from what essentially is human
neurochemistry and there's the most
potent ones are chemicals that exist in
the brain.
They're indogenous and the human body
and what have those experiences and how.
Why are they so akin to religious
experiences and why?
Why do people even believe now,
especially these scholars in Jerusalem
have connected the burning Bush of Moses
with the Acacia Bush,
which is a Bush that's rich and
psychedelic chemicals and they think
that it's entirely possible that Moses
had a psychedelic experience in which he
came back with all the laws that human
beings are supposed to be lifting as
proclaimed by the great spirit of the
universe or whatever the hell he
encountered.
Like who?
Who knows?
But this idea that people love to say,
you know,
God is dead.
There is no god.
Like that's just as silly as saying
there is one.
Right?
And,
and this is why like the,
like the whole process since we left,
like it wasn't a like.
I mean,
first of all,
like the idea of choosing belief system,
like I would like learn all this stuff
about Jehovah's Witnesses and like,
like,
okay,
yeah,
that's mostly internally consistent.
Like I think there's a lot of.
I never was tempted to join them or
whatever it actually say they're
actually,
they're not,
they're not witnesses anymore.
Like they,
they've,
since they left a little over a couple
of years ago,
do you think that you guys leaving and
having these intimate conversations with
them in their home might have had
something to do with the.
I am,
we're still really good friends with
them.
Like there's some of my best friends.
Um,
I don't,
I don't think that it was that direct of
a thing.
Part of the whole journey.
Yeah.
I mean I think so.
We would have these long conversations
and actually I was the craziest thing
when I found out that they had left,
like it was,
it was dustin,
the Laura,
her name is Laura.
It was her birthday and uh,
they don't drive,
don't celebrate birthdays.
Like I was talking on the phone and I
didn't even know it was her birthday.
It's like we were talking on the phone
for over an hour and I was like telling
her about all this,
all these things that I'd been thinking
about and like,
and then at the end of the conversation
she's like,
well it's my birthday today and I'm
celebrating it.
And I just was shocked.
I didn't say anything for a couple of
seconds like I.
Because I obviously like knowing what
that.
And it was different.
It wasn't as like as much for them,
you know,
like it wasn't the same level of.
But like I know the disorientation and
the loss and the like,
all of that.
It's complicated.
It's like you don't want to just be
like,
oh my gosh,
I'm so glad you're out of this.
Because they think they believe some
things that are really kind of nuts.
But,
but so I was just like very cautious.
Like,
like I don't know what happened but just
know that.
I mean,
I,
I've always loved and cared about them
and,
and you know,
like,
but I was so eager to have these
converts to,
to understand what had happened with him
and it's kind of just,
just following the,
like how much internal inconsistency.
Like when you were saying earlier about
the,
the idea about the Bible being the
infallible word of God and like,
Oh,
that's a neat trick.
There's no way you can argue around
that.
This is why.
Like it's I think internal inconsistency
in the doctrines themselves.
Like that's seems to be a really
important way to get,
to get in,
to get through that.
Like,
like to argue a seed of doubt.
Yeah.
Because that's it.
You have to.
It's finding the inconsistency in these
two beliefs that allows you to maybe
question the bigger things,
the bigger principles and anyway,
just I think it's,
it's important to ask the questions no
matter what you believe.
It's important to question and to always
be looking and examining for new
evidence because like,
yeah,
you talked about this a lot,
but like confirmation bias and cognitive
dissonance like these,
these things that keep us locked into
these belief systems and impervious to
change or we're not even in previous but
like resistant to it.
We want to be like open and so this is,
I mean,
I still try to do this and this is why,
like I do.
Do you ever want to look,
grab your mom?
You got to listen to me for an hour.
Just,
let's talk.
I would,
if she,
I would love to,
to her if she would listen to me,
but she,
she just won't even look at,
you know,
you'd be knocked on the door,
rang your doorbell.
Uh,
that,
that's happened a couple of times,
not me,
my sister.
And like they close the curtain the
window and turn off the lights inside
the.
Have that happened once.
But um,
yeah,
they,
they won't.
And this is why it's possible.
She might hear this.
Yeah,
she would listen to this.
I think it's,
I think it's possible.
I mean,
I think,
I think somebody at the church,
we'll listen to it for sure.
I mean,
so this is the thing like when people
leave,
like everything that we say most,
any of us who leave that we say and do
publicly,
the church pays very close attention to
it.
Like when I was at the church I did the
same thing.
And partly it's a like needing to know
like what they're saying so that you can
have a good explanation,
should counter it effectively or yeah,
points.
And uh,
but so this is why another reason why it
became evident that I couldn't hide
forever.
Like if I hiding following the rules,
you know,
pretending like none of this happened
and not causing any waves for the
church.
That doesn't change anything.
Like the only thing that helps is,
is talking about it like,
and,
and because here's the other thing,
like even if I like privately in,
in letters like,
or things that I sent to my parents or
other church members,
like they're not gonna,
they're probably not going to share
those with my siblings.
And if they do,
it's going to be with a whole bunch of,
you know,
words against me at the same time.
So like,
it's,
it's only by talking publicly can,
you know,
that's how they can actually see who you
really are and what you really think and
what you've really gone through without
the filter of look at what these tours
are doing,
things like that.
Like it's,
it's,
um,
do you think your kids are,
your brothers and sisters are going to
hear this?
I think some of them definitely might
definitely my hope that they'll
eventually bolt.
I do.
I hope that they not,
not because of any.
I hope they can hear the reasoning and
see,
see the consequences of what they're
doing for other people.
And that a lot of it,
I mean is unscriptural.
And so even even by their own
understanding,
like they,
there,
there are things that contradict them.
I hope that they change their minds.
And at the very least I hope that the
church continues to moderate to not be.
So a lot of their new signs are things
like,
uh,
another one of the big things for me was
imprecatory prayer,
right?
Which is this idea of this word
imprecatory to like record tour.
So it's like the word praying for curses
for your enemies.
Right?
Right.
So we did this.
You a curse against your enemies.
Oh,
I'm often,
yeah.
Wow.
That seems incredibly non Christian.
Right?
But there's a like David King,
David.
It is,
it's true.
We'll see.
This is the thing.
So like,
you know,
we,
we took that as an example for us.
So he prayed for his enemies,
for their children to be fatherless and
for their wives to be widows.
And so he's praying for God to do all
these bad things to the Romans.
He was praying against the Romans.
No.
Is it David the Philistines
and saw I guess,
but um,
but,
so we took that as an example.
Right?
So after we left,
I sent a is I contacted my,
it was my dad and uh,
talked about this problem.
So like David also had a lot of wives,
but we don't take his example as that.
Men should have many whys.
And what about that and why it was
because it contradicts what Jesus and
the Apostle Paul said about marriage
being one man,
one woman for life,
right?
So Jesus knew way,
So,
and Jesus and Paul both also said they
talked about loving your enemies,
bless them,
that curse you and pray for them that
despitefully use you and persecute you.
So you're supposed to be praying for the
good of your enemies.
Right?
Right.
And so it's,
it's,
it's a contradiction.
And so anyway,
it's another like a long time,
like there's been a bunch of sermons
like,
so now my grandfather passed away almost
three years ago and so now there's eight
elders and they're the eight pastors in
my,
my dad is one of them.
So there's been a series of sermons on
imprecatory prayer since then.
And they're like,
it seems like it seems so confused
because like on the one hand there still
kind of justifying it,
but also it just seems like you're
trying to reconcile things that aren't
reconcilable.
So,
so,
but a lot of the,
the,
so they stopped,
I should say,
there used to be a flyer that went out
every Friday and that used to say like,
thank God for 15 dead soldiers,
we pray for $15,000 more and so it would
list all the soldiers who had died that
week.
And uh,
within a,
like after like eight months,
you know,
my dad gave a sermon about imprecatory
prayer,
like at the time when I first said that,
you know,
there was a,
he put out a video news,
uh,
explaining like why imprecatory prayer
is the thing and it's supported by the
Bible.
Eight months passed,
he gives a sermon about loving your
enemies within a couple of weeks,
that flyer was changed.
Now it doesn't say that we pray for
15,000 more.
Um,
I haven't seen the first part is the
first part still thank God.
So they say because God is sovereign,
you have to thank him for everything.
So the fact that these for $15.
So the second part where I'm just trying
to say is like there,
there has been some moderation and a lot
of the new signs or things like be
reconciled to God and Christ our hope,
things like that,
like that,
that are not God hates fags.
Like those are.
I think that's,
I think that's improvement at the very
least.
Even though there are still obviously
these,
these harsh things as well.
So there's some adjustment and some
consideration.
Um,
you.
So you don't talk to your dad anymore
either,
right?
No one knows
is.
Wow.
Is there anything that you think that
you can do other than continuing to
speak and continuing to do what you're
doing that's going to reach them?
So I mean I am almost finished writing a
book.
I'm nearing the,
is it a book to them?
It's,
it is both for them and also for,
for other people.
There's part of the,
kind of what I was getting at was this
like you writing a book like letters to
my mom and dad.
So it's not,
it's not,
it's not written quite that way a lot as
well.
I actually did consider doing it that
way,
but eventually ended up,
like right now it's based on,
um,
each chapter is based on a relationship
that sort of brings us like the stars
with my mother and then my grandfather
and sort of like coming into this
ideology and then the process of all of
the,
like the mental machinations of,
of leaving and like how my mind changed
over time and then what's happened since
we left.
Like,
and I hope that by,
you know,
from my family,
I hope that by articulating these things
in,
in a way it's like obviously we're
sitting here and even if we talk for
like however many hours,
like there's only so much that it's not
the same as having it written in a way
that's hopefully very clear and,
and,
and just honest to the experience,
like in as much detail and clarity with
as much clarity as possible.
Like I think that that's,
I hope that that will be effective in at
least showing them that there's a
different way.
There are other ways of,
of understanding these things.
And so I do hope that,
um,
I guess I also hope,
like in my ted talk,
I,
I have,
I feel really,
I'm like hesitant about like trying to
teach anybody anything at this point,
you know what I mean?
Like,
because I spent my whole life telling
other people how to live and now it'd be
like,
well,
you guys know I got this,
now I got this,
you know,
like,
it just the idea of like,
insinuating even in any way that I have
something to tell people about anything.
Like I,
I'm,
I,
I really don't like that idea at all.
And the only reason I did the Jon Ronson
actually as the one who reached out to
me about,
about doing it because he,
it was a thing that he was curating an
event that he was curating,
curating.
And uh,
and so I wrote the first draft of the
talk and,
and the curators came back afterwards.
I was like,
well,
it's like this is how can we avoid the
mistakes that you made?
And so like I went back and like took
examples from David and my husband in
the way that people on twitter engage
me.
That actually helped,
helped change things but so,
so it's not explicit in that way in the
book.
But I hope that just
by talking about this and telling the
stories like I when I read accounts of
people who have gone through similar
situations,
it,
it's so helpful to me like to realize
like my family,
like yes,
they man up there,
their activities are,
are kind of,
they're extreme and they manifest
themselves in very strange ways to most
people.
But they're very common,
very human flaws.
And if,
if anything that,
if I talk about this in a way that helps
other people see it in their own lives
or that you know,
will resonate with people who have gone
through similar things like that.
I think,
I mean,
I,
that's,
I want to do that.
I want to do as much good with these
experiences as I can because just
because that's how my parents raised me
honestly.
But their argument,
of course it'd be,
you know,
you were so right and so convinced when
you were with the church.
Now you're so right and so convinced.
Now that you're outside of the church,
how do you know you're right now?
The latter is not the same.
It's not the same at all.
Like I'm not,
I do not walk through the world with a
sense of what that sense of certainty
and,
and in,
in my position and righteousness of my
position,
I am asking questions and I'm,
I'm trying to explain what,
why I believe differently now than I
did.
I'm still asking the questions that like
I never stopped.
Like,
you know what I mean?
It's,
it's,
it's such a fundamentally different way
of,
of engaging.
Yeah.
The world.
I do know what you mean.
But if I was on their side and I was
trying to pick holes in your statement,
which is what they seem to do,
right?
If they're listening to the things you
say,
they're listening to the things you say,
so they can counter them with some sort
of a bible quote or some sort of a more
articulate opinion.
Right?
If I was listening,
I would say you were so convinced when
you with us.
Now you're so convinced,
but now you don't even have God.
How could you be?
Right?
So the thing is,
you're diluted the Satan,
the serpent scales are covering your
eyes.
So this a shall I thought this is
another,
um,
another one of
paradoxes that I realized before I left.
So there's this verse,
and again,
this is one that my mom make was good
quote all the time growing up and with
such urgency,
like she needed us to understand this.
And,
and the versus the heart is deceitful
above all things and desperately wicked
who can know it,
right?
So.
So I thought the heart was good.
Homeless with the heart is.
No,
I thought I fell hard is people being
sweet.
And so
human heart is inherently and according
to the churches inherently deceitful.
Right?
Okay.
But the problem is they also talk about
the heart as being like,
that's how we know that the Bible is
true because God puts an unction on our
hearts are deceitful heart.
Yes,
exactly.
So you're at the end of the day,
it's always our own hearts.
Like it's our hearts that say,
okay,
well I'm going to follow the Bible no
matter no matter what.
Or in other words,
at the end of the day,
each one of us is always
making a decision.
It's just that for them,
they,
they think that outsourcing it and
saying that,
oh no,
it's the Bible.
It's like,
well,
you're the,
it's your.
I tried to articulate that's on Sam's.
Sam Harris was show a couple of years
ago,
like,
but it's that I read it actually in his
book,
like that's what helps me.
Like it's,
it's your own moral impulses that are
authenticating the truth of the Bible.
Right?
So at the end of the day,
it's still you.
It's still your judgment,
your judgment of your own deceitful
heart.
So again,
from their perspective.
So I guess what I'm saying now is like,
I'm not.
When I,
when I talked to my family,
when I'm addressing them,
like it's,
it's with these questions like,
I know how you understand these verses,
but what about these things that
contradict them?
I'm not saying you're wrong,
I'm saying I can't see how you're right
because of these versus how do you do
this?
Do you understand this?
What about versus the contradict other
verses in the Bible that the church
doesn't believe in that,
that,
that those contradictions exist.
Talk about those contradictions,
which are pretty clear.
What,
what do they say?
Well,
so the Lord works in mysterious ways,
right?
There's,
there's always that.
Like if,
if you think there's like for instance,
like back to the like free will and
predestination thing that God designed
for people to go to hell and then
holding them responsible.
So there's this.
This is a contradiction,
right?
This the idea that you are responsible,
Your man's responsibility and God's
sovereignty,
they don't go together.
So it's an awesome quote.
Can you say that quota go man's a man's
responsibility and God's sovereignty.
They do not go together with the quote
in the Bible.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I phrased,
um,
oh,
which is the navy o man who art thou
that reply against God.
Okay.
Yeah.
Shall the thing formed say to him that
formed it.
Why Hast Thou made me this?
So,
yeah.
So that,
those ideas are inherently.
They're inconsistent,
right?
Their contradictions.
And so gramps,
I remember one day in church,
he lives gramps.
Gramps.
Yeah.
Sounds like such a cute name is great
evil dude.
He could be so grandpa Tony and,
and like,
it's so funny because like again,
be funny.
Oh hilarious.
Yeah.
Sweet guy.
Very sweet.
He would sing the song from the forties
and call us my great big beautiful doll.
Like that's a huge call us and love bug.
And so you miss him.
Yeah.
You,
you didn't get to see him before he died
because you left.
Think I can talk about that.
I can't.
Not unless you're me to start crying.
Sorry.
Um,
uh,
but,
but yeah,
he's.
No,
no,
no.
He was that deep for all the stuff you
talked about.
Like you
can't talk to your dad,
you can't talk to your mom,
but something about your grandpa.
He's special.
Yeah.
I'll tell you later.
Okay.
Okay,
so in the eyes of most people,
he was the booming voice of hate for
sure,
and I totally understand.
It is not so fascinating though,
that you could see someone in an
intimate way you'd love them,
their family.
You get to see all the positive aspects
of them and yet do you get to see this
venom that he spews out to all the world
and then that also represents you guys
and your family and your ideology and
your behind this powerful leader.
He's the founder of all this,
right?
So essentially he's the man who created
the very bar.
Is that imprison your family right now?
I know and it's,
it's so,
and this is one of the things you know
after,
after I left,
like thinking about like how did we get
here?
It'll,
how did we end up in this place?
It's an understanding of psychology or a
lack of the problem with any sort of
ideology,
rigid ideologies that are backed up by a
deity is that there can be no
questioning and as soon as there can be
no questioning,
you're talking about human language.
You're talking about something that came
obviously from the words of human
beings.
They wrote those words down,
they put them somewhere and now you're
reinforcing this ideology.
Anyone with even a basic understanding
of how easily influenced people are and
about our alpha male chimpanzee history
or lower primate history.
We know that we're incredibly
susceptible to influence and incredibly
susceptible to the whims of the group
mindset and that this was imperative for
survival.
These tribal instincts that we have
imperative for survival and the reason
why we made it to 2017 and that these
play against us in the forms of ideology
and these very rigidly reinforced
behavior patterns mean that is what.
That's when the problem,
because atheism versus people who were
deists or people who are Christian or
Muslim or whatever the fuck it is.
It has nothing to do with that.
Honestly.
It's just about mind and about humans
and about our,
our,
our inherent tendency to give in to
these,
these predetermined patterns of behavior
to give us comfort in these patterns
that yeah,
there is so much comfort in certainty.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
it can be really frustrating.
All these,
sometimes all the rules and the like a,
like you said,
very rigid but,
but after when I left,
the uncertainty was just this enormous
weight.
Like I had no idea.
Like what do you normally wait on?
You just all of a sudden.
Yeah,
because like again,
well one,
first of all,
one of the things that makes doing
things like this hard or like speaking
publicly at all now that it's not like
me,
like with God on my side or whatever is
the idea.
Like now I'm standing on my own two
feet.
Like it's,
it's my own ideas and like who the hell
am I?
You know,
just that
sense of like self doubt and uncertainty
and,
and like it's,
it's just,
it's,
it can be crippling sometimes,
but,
but you just,
you have to keep going and keep asking
the question.
Like,
this is one of the things,
like you said,
uh,
I mean the whole another reason I don't
like to call myself an atheist or,
or to call myself anything actually,
Sam,
sorry,
I cannot stop talking about Sam Harris.
Um,
but he had this,
uh,
this video or he was saying,
well we shouldn't call ourselves
atheists or secularists or humanists
written to college.
So was anything we should just be good,
decent people living in the world and,
and challenging bad ideas wherever we
find them.
It's not about the,
I mean we want an identity like sugar,
crave identity and belonging in this,
like the,
the ingroup like what you're talking
about grants,
like how,
how much goodness I got to see in him
that like people on the outside never
saw.
It's because of that,
you know,
the Ingroup outgroup mentality.
Like the bar,
like I said earlier,
that bonds that are forged there.
It's so,
it's so enticing,
but,
but it comes at a,
at a huge cost and I didn't see that
cost for a long time,
so now this is another reason I don't.
I just don't like those labels.
It's not about the identity.
It's just about trying to find the best
way we can to live in the world and do
as much good as we can.
I think there are bumps in the road and
the evolution of culture.
I think that's what they are or think we
haven't figured out how dangerous they
are and that we fall prey to them,
but they're also the reason why we got
here in the first place because we did
figure out these ways to bond together
and we did figure out these ways to
identify with each other in this very
extreme,
a very personal way and if it wasn't for
those things,
who knows if we would have ever made it
this far,
who knows,
but they've also also been able to.
People have been able to rationalize
horrific acts through the use of this us
versus them.
You know,
the,
our group versus the other.
It's a very strange aspect of what I
believe is the adolescent nature of
human social and cultural evolution,
which is where we're at right now.
We've come so far we think,
but really we haven't.
We haven't really been around that long.
I mean they're talking about this in
this modern human being.
They found 300,000 years ago,
God,
that's a blip,
blip.
So it's a blink of an eye in terms of
the history of the world.
Nevermind the history of the universe.
And I think that it's very dangerous
when someone tells you they know it's
very dangerous because you don't know.
And she's like,
well,
if they know,
I'll just listen to them.
And that's what we've been doing forever
and I think people are recognizing more
and more now that that is,
that's not safe.
It's dangerous and it's an impediment to
progress,
personal progress,
progress as a community,
we have just as insane instinct to join
teams to the point where people,
they identify with certain patches,
a dirt.
I'm a Texan,
like,
oh,
you're a Texan,
so this is all okay,
you know,
hey,
I'm from New York.
Oh,
from New York.
Well that while I get you,
now I understand you.
You're in this nice little category.
You get to operate on these
predetermined patterns.
Now you know you've.
You don't even have to have your own
beliefs.
You just adopt a conglomeration of
beliefs that fit whatever category you
fall into with your left wing
progressive or a right wing
conservative.
So we're.
We're really weird.
Really Weird.
Monkey were so strange and we're also
aware how weird we are.
That's what I was going to say like that
is the,
that's where I feel so much and why I
feel so much hope,
right?
Because like the more awareness we have,
the better we can go about trying to
sort of shore those things up.
Yeah.
I could see the pitfalls and then try to
find ways around them,
but it takes people like you that
incredibly courageous,
that breakout of the pattern and,
and,
and just paddle out into the waters of
discomfort because that's what people
have a really hard time doing.
People have a really hard time changing.
They have a really hard time taking
chances.
They were really hard time doing new
things and you did all of it at once in
one big burst and you separated from
your tribe.
It was so important to you that you
separated from your tribe.
That's so hard.
Yeah.
Yeah,
for sure.
But it's.
And this is one of those things where
like,
I mean,
I was talking to David after I left
before the delicious festival.
You're sitting in the home of this rabbi
that I had protested earlier and,
and uh,
your rabbi as a horror was decided.
My sister held and like,
oh no,
like living with this rabbi.
Right.
Actually,
that's why I'm staying right here.
Well,
I'm here.
You're staying with a rabbi,
rabbi and his wife and their four kids.
How is a rabbi,
a whore that you,
that you pay them and they make you feel
good?
Like they tell you what you want to
hear,
that
it makes him a whore.
In that case,
is a comedian a whore too?
I must be a whore.
Yeah,
probably.
Yeah.
They're committing whoredom
prostitution.
But David said,
we'll give him massages.
Whores.
I wouldn't go there,
but they're making you feel good and you
pay them to you.
It's like,
okay,
so chiropractors would be horse.
Is that how it works?
I guess
David was like,
um,
it's like you are your parents children.
Like I'm just like sitting there bawling
and because I felt like such a betrayer,
this is again right after we left.
And uh,
and he said,
I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
well,
they're the ones who taught you to stand
up for what you believe in no matter
what it costs you.
And so I,
I,
I love that idea,
like that there's still so much from
home that I have held onto and that,
that still guides me.
It's just that I obviously had to,
it's just the,
the things that I now think are
destructive and hurtful and just not
true,
not,
not consistent with reality.
Um,
but that,
that gave me a lot of,
like,
a lot of hope.
Right?
Well,
you,
you definitely seek comfort and ancient
wisdom and quotes.
Who Me?
Yeah,
well it's hard.
Like here's the thing,
like it's.
So I remember I was,
there's a New Yorker article that came
out at the end of 2015 and so I was
doing interviews with the writer Adrian
Chen,
who's amazing and he's an amazing
writer.
Just just generally,
not that just that article,
but like as we're having these
conversations like,
like we,
I think we spent three days together in
Kansas talking about maybe six hours at
a time and then on on the phone like
three and four hour conversations
regularly.
Like it was so much like trying to
really get across all of these all of
this time to really understand exactly
how my mind changed all the details in
the church,
whatever,
like and at one point like we're talking
and,
and he asked me a question,
it was about the soldier's funeral I
think.
And I just immediately started like
coding all these verses and like.
And it's like Whoa,
you just went into this mode.
Like I can tell this is just like this,
like switching into this like,
like,
like it had been at the church.
Like it's just not possible.
Like even though I think that I don't
believe the Bible is the infallible word
of God,
but like I spent so much time like
reading it and learning it and
memorizing you know,
chapters at a time with my family and
all this stuff.
So it's like,
it's right there.
It's always like.
And they're like I said,
there is so much good in it.
So it's like,
I dunno,
it's just.
I know what you're saying is that,
that are,
it's,
it's comforting when you said it's a,
it sounds so foreign to hear the King
James,
but like to me it was just.
Sorry.
It's comforting.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's familiar and it's.
it's a part,
it's a part of my home and my upbringing
that I,
that I can keep
as a person outside of it.
Looking at it when someone starts
spouting out biblical phrases and terms
and using these parables and using these
stories and passages in the Bible to
justify things and then equating like
certain aspects of modern thinking and
behavior to those things.
To me it's almost like I'm looking at
mathematics that I don't totally
understand.
It's like,
I see what you're doing,
you're putting,
you're plugging this equation in to
achieve a desired result and this result
is um,
a,
a peace of mind,
peace of mind is what you're looking to
attain and you're looking to attain
justification for your lifestyle and
actions.
And you can do so with this quote,
which is essentially like you're,
you're,
you're plugging in some sort of
theoretical physics.
I mean,
it's a weird stretch of what I'm saying.
What I'm saying is just like the feeling
of it,
the feeling of it is like,
oh,
I don't lie.
This will.
Then you use this.
Oh,
and then is that okay and makes this.
So it's all these little tools in order
to operate the mind on a more harmonious
frequency for your own personal
satisfaction and your,
your feeling of happiness and peace.
Like you can feel comfort in the fact
that you have quoted the Bible verses
that explain your behavior correctly.
You have made the noises in the right
order.
Yeah.
And whether or not those noises make
sense at all.
And then when in doubt,
you throw in like some weird principle
like that God has a plan for everything,
so fuck you doubts,
you just stick that right in there and
like,
okay good.
So that's like dark matter.
Well where's all the mass dark matter
where you go,
oh,
okay.
You know what I'm saying though?
He gets like,
it's an odd sort of a thing because it's
the,
just the uncertainty and the lack of
knowledge,
like you don't understand.
It's something I don't understand.
It's okay.
It'll have to understand it because
somebody else understands it.
Also,
you're using tools.
It's also like you're using these,
these phrases and these tools and these
passages to achieve desired results
internally as well as externally.
You're,
you're,
you're using them to comfort yourself,
but you're also using them to,
to prove your point against these
others.
And that's a big part of what's going on
with this whole tribalism cult like
behavior.
It's justifying your own patterns of
thinking by demonizing and marginalizing
others.
Patterns of thinking.
Yes.
Okay.
So this is something that I,
I missed this for a long time too,
but like,
so my grandfather,
like I think I said earlier,
maybe the Christians were some of the
biggest targets at the church and I
spent so much time,
uh,
like the minor differences.
Yes,
exactly.
But I mean even like major differences,
like the hatred of God and you know,
like,
and you know,
people going to hell for eternity and,
and,
and why and all these things like,
like we spent so much time,
grams would instead of saying we are the
only ones who have it,
right?
Westboro Baptist church is the only true
church in the entire world and I'm 100
percent certain of that.
It was a different strategy.
It was attacking every other version of
Christianity,
every other understanding of the Bible.
And so,
and it's like by default it's like,
well you know exactly why all these
people are wrong.
Methodists and Catholics and whatever.
Like,
and you can articulate chapter in verse
why they're all wrong and therefore the
end,
like it becomes clear like we are right
and we are the only ones who are right
and everybody else is.
So it's just this.
It's so frustrating.
So frustrating.
Well,
I hate to use the word,
but it just,
it lacks enlightenment because it's
dealing with conflict and it's dealing
with finger pointing.
It's dealing with insults like just the,
the term fags God hates fags is using
that.
Like that in itself.
It's just like a giant red flag showing
the errors of your thinking in order to
even sit down and draw this poster.
Like do like this is,
this is not God's approach.
If there is a god the Bible,
I mean if there is a god that's in
charge of this whole thing and he's
filled with love and he has a plan for
us all.
Do you get super emotional when you're
talking about this stuff that you see?
You're all worked up.
Sorry.
No,
no,
don't apologize.
It's important.
Look,
I mean,
it's amazing how well you keep it
together without contact with your mom
and your dad and your brothers and
sisters and it's been four years.
How long enough?
Yeah.
Um,
well I totally lost my train of thought
there.
Okay.
You said something.
Well,
I was talking about just that,
the,
the insults and this.
Yeah,
so like the way,
like I always say people don't,
it's not the method that's the problem.
It's the message.
It doesn't matter how we say the
message.
People are still going to hate it.
Like if you,
if you say,
you know,
God created,
most people go to hell and we're were
among the only ones going to heaven and
sorry,
suckers,
you know,
like people hate that message,
right?
People hate the idea that you have to
like follow this set of rules.
Like you can't just live the way you
want to live.
You have to obey these ideas as we
understand them.
I'm like,
people don't like that message.
They don't want you telling them what to
do.
So that we would always make that
argument.
And then of course,
and you know,
after,
when I was thinking about leaving,
it was like,
of course it matters how you talk to
people.
Of course it does and even the Bible
talks about it.
So like,
you know,
in the New Testament Paul talks about,
to the Jews I became as a Jew and to the
Greeks as a Greek and do you know,
to the weak I became as weak because if
the idea is like you understand your
audience and who you're talking to and
you're actually trying to reach them,
you're not just self righteously,
you know,
proclaiming this thing and saying get on
board or you're doomed.
Like it's,
it's,
there's,
there was no we had and we,
we sometimes could have those arguments
one on one.
But like you know,
when we go out to these protests were
saying these things and it's so
provocative and inflammatory and we knew
it and we just did it anyway because we
thought it was justified as long as it
was true.
And it didn't matter how we set it or
when we set it or to whom we said it
well,
it was a grieving widow or a,
you know,
a child whose father had just died or
parents whose children had just died.
It's just,
it's,
it's insane to me now.
I can't,
I have a hard time like so,
so much of my history,
my past,
like I know why I believed what I
believed.
But sometimes that when I see these,
these contradictions,
I think,
what was I thinking when we were reading
these verses?
And I,
I don't,
I can't think of what they could be
thinking now except that it's just that
cognitive dissonance that just,
just,
just going past it and was like,
oh yeah,
that sounds good.
But like not seeing.
And you know,
there's another verse that talks about,
uh,
deceived,
hardest,
turned them Messiah.
So he can't even say,
is there not a lie in my right hand?
Like,
that's,
that's the feeling that I have.
Sorry,
back to the quoting her.
Great.
Yeah.
But anyway,
it's just,
this is why I think you're uniquely
qualified to sort of translate those.
And I,
I,
and that's the thing,
like,
I,
that's,
that's why I keep,
I mean,
I want to keep asking the questions.
It's not just about,
you know,
I think my family feels they feel
attacked.
I'm sure when I talk about this and why
I don't believe it and you know,
when I send these messages on twitter
and I remember what that felt like,
you know,
hearing people,
people that I had loved speak against
these doctrines and values that I held
so,
so dear.
Um,
but I,
it's not because I'm trying to hurt them
more or embarrass them or humiliate
them.
It's because I,
I want to help them see.
And if,
if I'm wrong about something then I want
to know that too.
So it's just,
it's always this like openness to change
into,
I don't know,
finding a better way.
One of the things you did that's
incredibly brave is not just leave,
but when you change your thinking and
change,
you have to admit that you fucked up big
time.
I have to admit that your entire life
has been essentially about propagating a
lie.
[inaudible].
There was a,
I had to say no weird Al Yankovic.
Here's a song that I'm listening to.
Everything you know is wrong.
Up Up is down,
black is wide and short as long as I
remember like in this process of like,
you know,
before we left,
like remembering that and being like,
I cannot,
I just thought of a weird Al Song.
But yeah,
that's totally what it just,
just coming to terms with like how,
how,
how wrong and how,
how could this have been for my entire
life and how can I possibly face this
like in my own mind,
let alone to all of these people.
I did it in front of the,
like in front of the whole world,
you know,
anybody who had seen like all the
documentaries,
all the times that I had so publicly
defended all these ideas and now
realizing like,
how can I possibly faced that?
Right.
If you were ever running for office as
the first thing that you go out,
look at Phelps in 2003 and the horrible
thing she was.
That's what they do,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
I think
your.
Your ability to say that you,
you don't agree with what you used to do
and you are a different person now is so
important for people to hear is one of
the most important things I think you're
saying because people feel so imprisoned
by their past.
It's a huge problem with human beings
that you repeat sort of the same
patterns of behavior because even if
they're wrong,
there's comfort and there's comfort in
going back to those cigarettes.
There's comfort in,
in binge eating.
Again,
there's comfort in gambling because I
know this.
I know this crazy rush of trying to find
crack.
I'm going for it.
I mean there's a lot of weirdness in,
in human behavior patterns and what
you've done is not just have real
intellectual courage to just actually
challenge your own personal thought
processes and ideas and look deep into
these scriptures that you've been
following your whole life and find these
contradictions,
explore these contradictions,
contradictions and try to debate them.
But also just to just to come out and
say like I was making just big mistakes.
I think it's really hard to say.
I mean a lot of things but,
but two things just for people in
general.
Like I messed up.
Yeah.
And I don't know,
like we have to be able to.
I mean,
I think to be able to an honestly like
this is another thing.
Like there's so much freedom in that.
In both of those ideas.
Like I said earlier,
like certainty.
There's so much comfort and certainty.
Like you don't have to wonder,
you don't have to doubt,
you don't have to question.
You can just go on your way and know
that what you're doing is exactly right.
And like,
there's so much comfort there,
but,
but in my experience,
it's a false certainty.
It's a false comfort because you're,
you're,
you're going along if you're not,
if you're not examining,
if you're not taking in new evidence,
if you're not like saying,
I don't know,
it's like I don't have to have all the
answers.
I can just say like,
I'm doing my best.
This is where I'm at now.
Like I'm,
I'm sure I'm gonna like find something,
I'm fine,
I'm going to find something else that
I'm at,
I've got wrong now and I'm going to keep
trying to get.
I'm going to keep trying to get better.
Like you don't want to become this
static,
you know,
you want to be able to,
to grow and learn and understand and do
better and as many ways as you can.
You're wrestling constantly with a
dangerous and volatile factor.
And that's uncertainty.
Yep.
And that is what people try to avoid
that soccer as much as they can.
Like I don't want that.
Right.
And just like learning to be comfortable
there.
Like I exist here and I exist in this
uncertain space because it's honest.
I don't know.
I don't have to know.
I can keep trying to understand and,
and you know,
so it's,
that's why one of the most,
the weakest things you could ever see in
a person is a person talking about
something in a way where like you ask
them a question about something and they
don't really know and they try to
pretend they do start to pontificate.
Yeah.
What you see it instead of saying,
God,
I don't know,
is that true?
Instead or instead of being like open to
the possibility of anything being
outside of the realm of their
understanding,
they double down,
double down on their ignorance or they
avoided at all costs and you see
literally see like the little,
the ban in the machinery,
the ego.
Just yanking on the gears frantically.
You could see it.
We all recognize it.
It's one of the more fascinating things
to me about religion in general is that
there we have this incredible desire to
become a part of a group.
I mean everybody does.
We find comfort in these groups,
but we also can see the gears spinning
when someone does agree with something
or someone does say something that
resonates or or so when someone says
something that's contradictory,
we see the gear spinning,
we that this is all some sort of a weird
cognitive dance that we're doing to try
to make,
make sense out of this temporary
existence on a planet hurling through
infinity
[inaudible].
It's insane.
Yeah,
but it's human and it's,
it's the human of today,
you know,
it's the human where we find ourselves
existing in communicating that clearly
is on some sort of path,
some sort of weird path of progress and
of innovation and of understanding that
we're in the middle of.
We're in the middle of the storm of
understanding and it's happening like
clearly in your own life and you're
living in,
out in front of the whole world.
Yeah.
And on that note,
that's good way to wrap it up.
We did already two hours and 45 minutes,
believe it or not.
Yeah,
just flew by.
Yeah.
You're a brave person and I think it's
really important what you're doing.
Massive really is super hard to do I'm
sure.
And uh,
the fact that twitter is what started
twitter so much,
I just,
I can not,
like you were saying earlier about like,
oh there's only 140 characters like Joe
just twitter,
but here's the thing,
like it's so crazy like twitter,
like the fact that it's only 140
characters,
like nothing taught me how to be more.
Like I'm very verbose pr I talk a lot
but like in writing and then I do the
same thing in writing but like on
twitter,
like it taught me to like distill my
ideas and become concise and it stopped
me from using.
That was one of the things,
one of the ways that I stopped like
insulting people instinctively because
like we did,
we did it so much.
Like we would write these elaborate
insults like responding to emails and
stuff because like obviously an email
you can write as much as you want.
But like on twitter,
like so it's two things like one on the
end and 40 characters.
It's like throwing a,
you idiot.
Like there's an just,
there's no space for it,
but also like when I did do that,
like there's this immediate feedback
loop that you get so like you can watch
the conversation derail in real time and
then realized like,
okay,
no,
I just need to not like because it just
instead of addressing the arguments,
like then you're saying like,
you know,
you,
like you don't know me,
they rusty know they'll answer and like
it just,
it,
it stops,
it stops the conversation like you want
it to be about the points are there was
like I learned so much about
communication from twitter and I just
love it so much.
Like it's just a tool,
like it depends on how we use it.
I use it a lot and I learned a lot of
things on it.
I mean I'm constantly being sent
articles and that's where I found out
about the 300,000 year old human and I
mean every day someone sends me
something and I retweet it.
Just it's,
we got connected.
Yeah,
there you go.
So there you go.
More twitter.
Yes.
Your book is coming out.
When I
don't know yet,
I haven't seen the last draft.
Uh,
and I,
I'm not even going to tell you the name
right now because I really want a
different name.
Okay.
And tell me.
Yeah,
I'm not going to tell you.
Sorry.
What'd you say,
Jamie?
Okay.
Um,
if people want to see more of your
stuff,
I know you have a Ted talk that's out
there.
Uh,
my twitter account is just Megan folks.
Um,
yeah.
I said,
well,
yeah,
there's going to be the book but uh,
well when the book comes out,
come back on again.
We'll do it again.
Alright.
And we'll tweet out your book and let
everybody know and,
uh,
really enjoyed this conversation.
Thank you so much.
Very much.
Thank you for being so brave to huge.
What you've done is huge for a lot of
people listening to this.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
See You tomorrow on five.